the chauvin trial up in minneapolis
is tainted two jurors had to be removed
because the city moved
to settle with the george floyd family
for a record sum of 27 million dollars
they had to bring in all the jurors they
had to ask them all questions about
did you hear anything about a civil suit
and a couple people were like
27 million dollars ain't no joke the
city basically admitted
fault in this uh in the scenario these
two jurors got removed
there's my understanding is not going to
be a delay the defense wants a delay but
who's going to assume
this guy's going to get a fair trial at
this point now part of this settlement
was five hundred thousand dollars it's
going to the community currently
occupied by extremists at 38th in
chicago
they're calling it an autonomous zone
because activists have
erected this giant black lives matter
communist fist
they've put up barricades around the
area and residents
recently penned an op-ed with a star
tribune
and it is horrifying no it's not funny
it's it's it's
absolutely horrifying the people who
live here are writing about how cops
don't come
a 30 year old volunteer was shot and
killed on multiple nights 30 gunshots
ringing out children running and hiding
bullets riddling people's homes and
garages this may be
we've talked about autonomous zones
we've talked about antifa and these
extremists
this one's apparently been going on for
like nine months and it's being ignored
by basically everybody and i don't
necessarily know why now with the
chauvin trial
happening it's starting to get some
attention
and so i read this op-ed they said
revolution by day de-evolution
by night it's actually rather horrifying
what they write about
some some some people there got an
argument about a parking space so some
random person just opens fire into one
of the vehicles
apparently this has been going on all in
the matter of like one week
there's probably hundreds of gunshots
that have rung out people running and
hiding people almost getting hit in
their own homes
that's what's happening right now in
minneapolis and why well because
extremists have taken over the area
because cops can't get in
because cops don't want to get in
because cops have been fired and the
city defunded the police now they got to
spend millions to bring these
these these officers back it is it's
it's a
um i guess a portent of what's to come
if you defund your police and you allow
these people to take over
you can actually see what the locals are
saying so we're going to get into all
that
and uh we are joined today by the one
and only jack murphy what's up tim
ian lydia good to be back every other
wednesday
jack murphy i'm here i'm excited let's
do it
i'm glad you're here jack i'm so happy
to be like the shirt that says rogue
it's the only brand i'll rep besides my
own oh that's hot hey guys what's up ian
crossland in the house
obviously you can go to ian
crossland.net if you want a little more
of that ian you're holding something
you're right tim i thought it was his
grandma blanket
this is one of two colors of our new i
am a gorilla diamond hands t-shirt
although i hear it's a misprint
yeah that one was i guess printed too
dark came out a little dark here here's
the other one
yeah they teespring hit me up or they're
just called spring now and they're like
yeah we kind of you know
didn't do this right we're going to send
you some some corrected ones so you
can't see his hands
but so but so you know we could do we
could give these away they're not nearly
as shocking and offensive as the other
misprint that happened
but uh we can we can give so give this
away so we'll probably we'll figure
something else out with that maybe just
randomly sent to uh members at
timcast.com
we'll pull a bunch of random emails and
then send an email saying you know we're
gonna send you a free shirt
because uh we have 30 of them there's 15
men's and 15 women's
and uh it's it's the diamond hands
gorilla shirt where basically we have
that meme about amarilla because of you
know alex jones
this gorilla is wearing a suit and tie
holding wads of cash with sunglasses on
while he's smoking a cigar
because this guy knew what it meant to
hold on to his gamestop stocks
and uh once the price skyrocketed then
he cashed out and got rich
those attendees have done well for him
looks like a split in his mouth
it's supposed to be a cigar don't say
that
it looks like one so go to timcast.com
uh
shop you can get your own diamond hands
gorilla t-shirt we also got it pinned in
the chat
and that's uh always greatly appreciated
and uh and become a member of
tempest.com because we'll have you know
exclusive members-only content as we
usually do nice material by the way
yeah the shirts are really nice yeah i
like this one the one thing we hear from
everybody is they're like you know if
like
there were a series of misprints that
went out but they really love the
quality of the show
high quality products haynes that's the
company
apparently there's like a biodegradable
like uh uh eco-friendly one
i don't know only the best from spring
when they make the the misprint but
anyway anyway
we have a spatula let's press another
button if the cameras are moving i'm
here pushing buttons
someone's got to push the buttons hello
button pusher hello you know look we're
having we're having a lot of fun we're
having a laugh
uh we are jackson join a nice a nice
beverage
i am i'm drinking a beer uh since that
went so well
last time you're gonna shout out
starting off with this uh it was a local
harper's fairy beer uh i don't know
anything about it but i'm drinking it
and it tastes very good they're amazing
can i just we're basically doxxing
ourselves by giving them a shout out but
they deserve it man there's harper's
harpers ferry california yes
the best california i drive i drive from
dc to california every other wednesday
worth it
it's worth it is there a harper's ferry
in california
but if somebody somewhere is googling
well the brewery's not really
the brewery's not really in harper's
ferry but uh we we
we went up there and we grabbed a bunch
of their beers and uh we try to make it
up there
so often and we decided by a whole bunch
and i'm not a big beer drinker but it's
good stuff
it is good stuff it's 6.2 lager so i'm
feeling it is that good that's good oh
it's like 100 cans i think right i think
about it we bought it that would be that
would be 98 now because oh
but bottles of beer on the wall when we
have
when we have guests and they're like i
would like a beer we're going to be like
we have bud light
no offense to budweiser you know that
beer is amazing and if you'd like to
send over a pallet
and or sponsored the show we'd be
entirely open
but it's cool to be like you're only
going to get this beer here while you're
in town unless you go to harper's ferry
but
that's what we got it's like a
grapefruit blend isn't it this this beer
is
is high-powered clips in a can this is
how i'm seeing it so let's go for it
guys come on well so the reason i wanted
to kind of start off a little slow
and kind of just be silly and have fun
and talk about beer and stuff because
this this subject is going to get dark
dude the chauvin thing is crazy i don't
know how this guy can get a
fair trial but we're going to get into
it thank you and before we do go to
timcast.com become a member
we had we had lieutenant colonel alan
west on the show yesterday that dude is
incredible i was
uh so honored and humbled that he wanted
to come on the show and talk about
uh you know his the issues that that are
relevant to him and his career and
military service so i was incredibly
honored and i guess everyone really
loved him being on the show
afterwards we did an exclusive segment
with him where he talked about critical
race theory wokeness how it's affecting
politics and of course he's no fan
it was a really interesting conversation
i have to admit i probably a lot of
opinions you've heard from a lot of
people but it's it's
it's interesting to hear it from you
know a veteran and of both
the political space as well as the
military so go to timecast.com become a
member don't forget to like share
subscribe if you really do like this
show
leave us a good review on itunes spotify
if you haven't already check that out
you can you can get it there
now we're going to get dark and that's
why i was like let's let's go slow a
little bit with this one because
when i saw this op-ed this is from march
15th star tribune
near george floyd square revolution by
day the evolution by night
i saw this and i'm like oh this'll be
interesting you know they're going to
talk about you know antifa
i actually assumed they were going to be
i thought it was going to be positive
i thought they were going to be like
these activists have come and they've
helped us and
they've brought all this goodness and
and organization
and then i just got a couple paragraphs
in and it just got
so incredibly dark i'm scared for these
people man
i'm scared for what's going on and it's
it's it's horrifying to me that
you know they they have the like
barricade saying no way no
no as in like mentally no justice
and i'm willing to bet there are a lot
of well-to-do liberal types
they hear about this stuff these
autonomous zones and they're like good
for the activists
they don't care about the locals they
don't care about what they're saying and
they will do nothing to help these
people
this story i'm not going to read through
every little bit of it but
i'll read a little bit right now to give
an introduction to what's going on they
say
as neighbors of 38th street and chicago
avenue also known as george floyd square
or the autonomous zone
we are witnessing a revolution by day
and a de-evolution by night
prayer gatherings cancelled rallies
cancelled visitors arriving with flowers
in hand only to retreat to their cars
when greeted by the sound of gunshots
neighbors ducking for cover behind our
houses children in tow
the spiritual health of our community
the feeling of being connected to
something larger than ourselves is
collapsing
here's an account of some of the events
of the past 10 days on
one block adjacent to george floyd
square
where police are met by hostile groups
when responding to our repeated 9-1-1
calls
march 6 5 45 pm a 30-year-old volunteer
is killed in the zone by gunshot
people in the zone are seen picking up
shell casings and throwing them into
city garbage
loading the gunshot victim into a car to
drive him to the hospital
8 20 pm neighbors call 9-1-1 again
as multiple shots ring out children
listen march 7th
six garages along our alley are hit by
gunfire
one with its owner inside a car crashes
through a fence into a family's backyard
an 18 month old had been playing by the
fence minutes earlier
5 pm 30 shots hit cars and windows
and siding of at least one house
narrowly missing residents watching tv
parents and children out biking and
walking on a sunny day duck behind
houses
children watch bullets kicking up dust
in the street
a zone leader visits a bullet-riddled
house to comfort the family
while others from the zone are observed
picking up shell casings behind her
march 8th 2 30 pm multiple shots fired
a man is photographed perched atop cut
foods with an assault rifle
on a tripod children cry zone medics are
offered
to visit neighbors and provide mental
health support
to those being traumatized 9 50 pm
30 shots ring out a person complains to
a neighbor that the neighbor is parked
too close to the person's car
a zone occupant with no connection to
the other parties
fires multiple shots into the neighbor's
car and house
the neighbor a military veteran is in
the driver's seat and recognizes an
assault rifle with a 30
round clip the shooter walks back into
the zone
four police squad squads caravan through
and meet the neighbor nearby
10 16 pm a second 911 call provides a
description of the shooter
who remains in the area appearing to
wait for some target
police have just received a call about a
teen and adult shot two miles away
resources exhausted the police do not
respond to our call
the shooter in the zone walks away 10 45
pm third
call of the night as some neighbors are
picking up shell casings
people near the first statue in the zone
repeatedly yell get the f out of here
then a gun is fired from near the first
statue four men come out of the zone to
tell neighbors they weren't shooting at
you
the neighbors asked if they are zone
security and are told no
but one man reports he has his gun
neighbors ask how to protect themselves
and are told
the best thing to do is fill the street
corners of garbage containers
to block off our streets there's more
there's more i'm not going to read
through literally everything
they just talk about 9 15 p.m march 12
30 shots from inside the zone
i'll point out a few things i think need
to be corrected i do not believe
this they mention a person you know
witness it recognizes a
a third an assault rifle with a 30 round
clip i do not believe
there was someone there with like a clip
fed m1 garand
that was modified for full auto or
something like that i think star tribune
the people who live in this neighborhood
don't know much about guns
and what they're actually saying is that
someone had a rifle of some sort with a
30 round magazine
i if it is true however that they do
understand the context of assault rifle
meaning select fire rifle
what they're telling us is that somebody
was perched atop a building in this area
with a fully automatic rifle
on a tripod now i really doubt it was
full auto this person probably was just
thinking they were going to protect the
neighborhood
and they mounted a ar-15 of some sort
rifle
semi-automatic on a tripod with a
30-round magazine
i don't know why they would need to do
that unless the police have been
defunded
extremists have taken over the area and
residents are now cowering in fear
and you know what's interesting they say
medics are being provided for those who
are being traumatized
you know typically when we hear about
these antifa zones and trauma
we usually fan it off like a bunch of
weak pathetic college kids who think
hearing a fart is going to make you
is going to traumatize you or that
journalist who fired an ar-15
probably a 556 and then got ptsd from
doing it
no i think these families are absolutely
going to be suffering ptsd because it
sounds like they're in a war zone
cars crashing through a fence 30 rounds
ringing out
at some point a 30 year old being shot
and killed we heard about that story
when it happened
the police tried to come and render aid
they were barred and then what happens
in these autonomous zones
the extremists pick up the evidence the
shell casings and they destroy
all the evidence when when the security
in the i believe was the chas
executed those kids for 10 minutes were
just unloading round after round
hundreds of rounds they reported
what did they do afterwards well the
police couldn't get in so they stripped
the vehicle of evidence so that nobody
would
know who did it and what they did now
it's been happening in minneapolis
all while we have this trial going on i
don't know how
you have a i can't believe they're
having this trial for chauvin
in minneapolis right now they need to
move him to bumpkinville somewhere
far away from all of this stuff all of
the press all of the gunshots all of the
settlement
and then just let people in different
community hear this because there's no
way this guy's getting a fair trial
this is this is where we're at man i
think that's the point right like
why did they overcharge them in the
first place why did they why was the
settlement number
public aren't settlements usually
private isn't that the whole point a lot
of times
is we're gonna settle this and not talk
about the terms i guess it's the city so
maybe they have to reveal it
but it seems to me if you're going to
settle and put that statement of that
number out there
what you're basically saying is we think
we're guilty and you know why settle it
now
why did they settle now it was
sabotaging the trial
yes absolutely yes uh they sabotage
everything is about sabotaging this it
seems to me that they're setting us up
for
a tinderbox it is a tinderbox it is
being stuffed filled with kindling
they are just waiting for the spark i
don't get how people are calling 9-1-1
from inside the zone to police outside
the zone and
it's not being treated as like a hostage
situation it's it that's what it sounds
like it's like a federal hostage
situation and the city is not willing to
well biden's not going to do anything
well the city itself they're the ones
these are the people that actually
defunded the police after all the riots
right these are one of the jurisdictions
actually did they did so the elected
officials believe that the people that
elected them
put them into power to make decisions
like this to defund the police
could you imagine living like that i
look man i i i
everybody knows i grew up on the south
side of chicago i remember i'd be you
know sleeping and you hear pow pow in
the middle of the night
and you just you just you steal you're
laying down so what can you do
you know go to the floor if you hear it
closely but usually it's far away
i remember hearing from a friend of mine
i was talking him on the phone late at
night because we were gonna go skate or
something
and then he's like oh dude hold on a
second i
yeah there's a couple people dragging
dude they're dragging a body
he basically said what he told me was
that he saw two people going through an
alley carrying
a rolled up carpet with feet sticking
out the back of it even
even drunk in a place like this i could
not imagine 30 rots
30 shots ringing out cars crashing
through fences dude they're shooting
into cars with people in them they're
shooting into people's garages like
through
the garage now if you read the police
bought or from washington dc from any
given day you're going to have all of
those things on there yeah but
that's what i'm saying plus 10 extra
murders plus all kinds of over like
it's insane and if you read the police
waters from my neighborhood even where
there's like a million dollar houses it
terrifying but this is all within
basically what like 50 yards of the same
intersection they said
in this op-ed this is one block that's
insane one block so
it's it's they call it 30th they're
saying 38th in chicago is the george
floyd square
so there's probably four adjacent blocks
you know going to one going you know
east west north and south or whatever
the directions they have built
maybe it's mates north by northwest or
something and uh
this is one of those blocks adjacent to
the memorial
we've we we write about that story man
where the 30 year old volunteer was shot
and killed but this is just so much like
what happened in seattle
you'd think the first time this happened
then
police would take it seriously but but i
want to add to this
when will there ever be a federal
response to what's going on with these
extremists because i i'm willing to bet
you know they mentioned that one of
these guys who was shooting at nothing
to do with the neighbors who are arguing
i'm willing to bet we call them the
tourists
right so you know since occupy me and
several of uh
many journalists friends of mine we
would notice there were always these
similar people we would see at the same
events we knew their names
we called them tourists because they
would even fly to china
a couple of them flew to turkey to
engage in protests
for what reason are you in china
protesting okay there's a lot of things
protests in china for sure
but they were protesting mainland china
for like very specific chinese domestic
policy
and i'm like what is this who are these
people why are they doing this i bring
this up not to say that you know i don't
know what that is they're doing
how many of these people in the
autonomous zone are not from minnesota
how many of them crossed state lines
potentially armed
and and are committing these crimes
burning man was canceled this year
so look if you look at the murder
numbers this is happening all over the
country
murder numbers are back up to their
1990s levels wow
1990s which is coming out of like when
dc was called the most you know the
murder capital of the world
dc was dc dc was the murder capital of
the world wow
in the late 80s and that's when i first
moved to dc and that's when i got my
first choice
as well thanks dad that's when i got my
first taste here
so um you know on one hand this really
makes me feel
sympathy for people that do live with
this kind of violence
and it's not maybe as extreme but they
do live with it i mean we're talking
hundreds and hundreds of murders in dc
with a population of 500 000
yeah that's a lot okay per capita and it
was so bad
that after the 1968 riots the city gets
burned out
crack cocaine crime everybody
everybody left the city anybody that
could lead the city left the city
and anybody that could leave the city
anybody that could
the could is the key there yeah people
who are impoverished
get trapped in these places and it
creates a cycle of poverty crime and
violence
totally and when i was doing real estate
development in the 90s we would go
around rehabbing houses and i remember
specifically there were always
the houses always had bars on the
windows some of the houses had bars on
the doors and the windows
some of them had bars on the windows on
the second floor okay
but the cake wow the cake is when i
figured out
when i had did a house that had bars on
the roof hatch
on the inside on the second floor of
their townhouse there's a roof hatch to
go up into the attic and up into the
roof
they had bars inside their house on the
second floor
roof hatch because they were they had to
pay somebody to come in there and weld
it and it's
because someone broke into their because
people had been breaking into homes
through the attics and
invading people's houses so that's like
a level of violence that people were
accustomed to in the 80s and
in the early 90s in dc this sounds
familiar on the heels of what riots
breakdown of order people moving out the
police stepping back
and just allowing this crime to take
over by design in this case
this is this is a war zone what they're
describing yeah
i've been i've been in civil conflict
i've not been in full-scale war
i have not reported from places where
you've got you know
active you know belligerent militaristic
national whatever
but i have been in countries i was in
egypt during the revolution i was in
ukraine during
you know a lot of that conflict molotovs
were being thrown
people were getting shot venezuela i'll
tell you this based on what they're
reporting
i felt safe like reading this and i'll
preface this with i
i don't know what it's actually like to
be there on the ground but when i was in
venezuela
nowhere near as scary if if what they're
going through right now with an
autonomous zone
sounds more deadly than caracas which is
the murder capital of the world now
i can only imagine i mean something's
got to be done about it
this is this is i mean look there's
photos i guess there's a photo of a
giant
black lives matter communist fist right
in the middle
is this what what people can expect when
this this ideological faction continues
to gain power and expand
all right here's two things that are
really important one black lives matter
and antifa should be acting as
decentralized cells not trying to hold
a territory like this and using politics
and other punctuated moments to get
their agenda across
holding territory for them seems like a
strategic failure
right because they're just setting up
this environment which they can be
blamed for virtually
everything right but at the same time it
strikes me as being
so bad for them such
a polit uh propaganda failure
right that it seemed if i were designing
a circumstance to make black lives
matter and antifa look bad
i would encourage people to go to this
autonomous zone and start shooting
things up and start blowing things up or
you would encourage them to create the
autonomous zone because you know what
what invariably leads to when cops don't
come anymore it seems like such a bad
idea
and maybe they're this just this stupid
but it seems like such a bad idea that
it feels like it's somebody else doing
it it's like an info i mean look
they the the fist symbol they use is
literally the communist
fist symbol you know so i'm not going to
pretend that a lot of these people
realize what it is like they don't know
the core ideology behind a lot of what
they're doing
there are a lot of people who and this
is to be fair and be
respectful support black lives matter
because they genuinely believe police go
around
hunting down black people thousands in a
year right and it's not true
it is the big lie pushed by the media
over and over again
and the algorithms of big tech to
convince people basically the apocalypse
is happening
and it's just not true are there
problems yes should cops bail
accountable when they break the law
absolutely
should we shall we get an inquiry and
investigation whenever someone dies then
of police officer you bet
whenever someone dies we should figure
out what happened but these people
have adopted a fringe violent extremist
ideology
and right now you know what they're
saying these articles come out and
they're like racist extremists are the
biggest threat
white supremacists are the biggest
threat okay okay sure fine
i don't care if you want to say that the
biggest threat by all means law
enforcement do your job
target the biggest threat but can we
have a real conversation about how
serious this threat is as well
so i'll say it's not the biggest threat
but it's certainly a big threat
to whom threat to whom civilians
well who who are white supremacists the
biggest threat to
oh minorities but we know that that's
not actually the way
it's supremacist what do you mean well
the number of murders of black people
committed by other black people
far exceed any white supremacy murder
can we get a fact check on that
i'm pretty darn sure about that it far
exceeds going
so uh white people more are more likely
to kill white people black people are
more
black people are more likely to kill
black people yeah so you know in these
areas it's particularly interesting when
you have
white progressive antifa types going
into minority areas and burning down
black businesses and contributing to
that that castness conflict
but but i think they're specifically
talking about terror and political
not not like random street violence and
muggings
right so here's the irony of that it's
written by the
the white dominant i'm using their words
white dominant
supremacy culture the white oppressive
structures the government
is saying that the biggest threat is
white supremacists to whom
well to the government they're not
actually they're saying terrorism
right but they're not actually talking
about who the threat to
to minority people they're very
specifically coming at it from a white
power structure perspective saying i see
i see white supremacists are the biggest
problem so
ironically if minorities are picking up
that as
as as a position i don't think that's
actually what they're saying
i i see what you're saying they
definitely fear the threat from the
queue people
and you know far-right groups storming
the capital and stuff but we just had
that
that attra that atrocity happened with
that incel guy
who went to the asian massage parlor so
this is
what i'm saying i'm not here to argue
they're wrong
by all means if the experts come out and
say
racist extremists and white supremacists
the biggest threat we face i say
well then thank god you guys are on top
of this one no joke
if you guys are actually tracking down
the extremists they're going to stop the
violent criminals from getting
committing atrocities then i'm glad
you're there because we don't want that
to happen
okay great now do you have any extra
police or federal agents that can stop
the autonomous zone extremism that's
putting people under occupation and
making them live in fear
and under violence into the boot of
these extremists because i don't
understand why they can't do that i
don't understand
why they can send out a dozen agents for
for a garage pole rope
for that nascar driver because they
thought it was racist
but they can't do anything to stop this
because the government doesn't want it
in minneapolis in minnesota the people
don't want it the elected officials
don't want it
the city councils are the ones that move
to defund the police
that entire community is affecting sorry
infected top to bottom apparently with
this mind disease
right and the part that you pointed well
not at the bottom these are the ones who
are in the op-ed saying people are
fleeing and we refuse
sure we want our city back sure so
they're coming into close contact with
reality
now what all this all these people are
like oh yeah black lives matter to fund
the police i for
i'm all for that who could be against
black lives matter well this is what
happens when you've been taken
as a unwitting foot soldier in a war
where you don't know what the end goal
really is
or any of the ideology behind what
you're doing what you're saying
and you just become a pawn and now these
people are figuring out that they're
pawns
but there's no one in that political
apparatus that wants federal agents to
come in there and fix this
or state troopers to come in there and
fix this and they've already told their
local police not to fix it this is what
they wanted
that's true so i i feel bad for these
individuals who are there
yes now now coming face to face with
these policies
and you know what i'll add on top of
this first and foremost anybody who's
facing a distressing war-torn
chaotic moment like this you got my
sympathy and i want you to get the right
if you come to me
and you're like hey man i was wrong
defining the police was a big mistake
please can you help us i will say yes
yes so if they're coming out there
saying that now i will also say to all
the people who voted for it and still
sit back and say it's a good thing well
then you you get what you deserve
yeah you vote for it you want it don't
don't i'm not going to interfere i've
been thinking about this
that's democracy 15 minutes during war
world war ii i think 20 million
soldier deaths 50 million civilian
deaths or something like that the number
was like two to one
in war and that's in like an organized
soldier on soldier conflict when you see
this
city violence it's the civilian death
and destruction that is just goes
under the radar but you know what you
know what i gotta say it
if you don't pay attention to the news
if you do
nothing evil triumphs but the problem
that yeah i agree with you 100
you got a dick the problem that we have
today is the world has become too
complex and it's impossible for an
individual to make sense of the world
determine right and wrong
up from down it is impossible to do that
today
right because we live in a purposefully
polluted information space it's
impossible for anybody working
yes outside of that space you know so
you you expect the journalists to
distill this information and give you an
accurate world view so you can make
better
better choices instead what you get now
is rage bait garbage
ridiculous stories drama con you know
articles
so-and-so is fighting with so-and-so or
whatever that's what you get yeah here's
the latest bigot tucker carlson is now
donald trump saith brian stelter
oh we know why he did that because cnn's
ratings dropped by
something like 50 some odd percent and
then another like 47 in the key demo
so they they're they're they're on dire
straits they're the only white devil
they need a new villain yeah to to
report on
to keep everyone all going crazy it's
not gonna work no one cares about tucker
carlson brian
no they tried doing marjorie taylor
green but nobody cares about a freshman
congresswoman
okay well how about tucker he's got the
biggest show on fox news sorry bro
people are hitting me up a lot of people
hit me up and they're like tim
youtube is suppressing my channel right
now what's happening as soon as the
election was over they started hitting
my channel like no no
no no one's suppressing your channel
nobody cares
okay during i mean look we did we you
were on the show on january 6th
we had like you know 80 000 people
watching 100 000 a million views in the
first
night live viewership and then like 800
or 900 000
you know video on demand views and now
viewership goes way down
because we're coming off of that
political season fortunately for us
we're
a small podcast with you know small
business
things are going well but for cnn oh no
they're
they're they're getting crushed and it's
getting it's getting brutal to finish
that last point though on this
complexity of the world
it was once upon a time i believe
rational to be ignorant
of politics you're not going to be able
to deduce everything
you're not going to be able to figure it
all out and make a vote that's going to
count
right because it's never just but side
by one vote so there was a little
rationality to being ignorant
but today it is irrational to be
ignorant if you are
ignorant and you just accept what's
given to you over the mainstream media
and through the legacy and through our
institutions
you will end up fat sick chained to a
desk
in debt working for a corporation
wearing a mask staying at home
putting your kid in quarantine next to
you listen to him cry
out for you and you'll think that we
live
in a world where white supremacy is the
biggest problem and that black lives
matter just means we want black people
to have a good life
that's what happens when you don't pay
attention let's do this you're bringing
this stuff up
and you know we'll we'll derail a little
bit from the main conversation but i
want to show you this tweet
so i saw this uh earlier and this guy
joe hart tweets translation how to tell
you're a loser
did you see this tweet i retweet i
retweeted it myself so
this woman her twitter handle is cats
against humanity says how to tell you're
an adult
you gain 30 pounds overnight you'd
rather sleep than go out
everything hurts comfort comes before
style
you have a favorite spatula everything
feels like a chore
college students look like 12 year olds
you're always annoyed af
you know you know what i thought as soon
as i saw that that you do have a
favorite spatula
no no no you're depressed yeah that
lady's depressed she's depressed this is
not normal
yeah is this what people are
experiencing it's so much so
that that she's experiencing depression
and she thinks it's normal because she
sees other people experiencing this
that she's like it's just being a normal
adult no lady dude
you are in serious trouble okay listen
if you're gaining 30 pounds overnight
what are you eating and why aren't you
getting physically active are you just
sitting around and eating garbage food
sounds like you got a favorite spatula
you'd rather sleep than go out dude that
is a principal sign of depression
indeed for everybody listening if you
would rather sleep then go out
force yourself to go on a walk now what
what does that girl do though she's like
she's like some sort of
creator right i have no idea i think she
is she's a creator i click through
maybe her brand maybe she monetizes
being depressed you know that's messed
up
you see those commercials like we know
life is hard like they'll start off like
that they're trying to sell you a drug
or something like a pharmaceutical
life is hard and it's gonna get worse
like let's everyone just
accept this premise that life sucks so
that we can sell you our product yeah
antidepressants
she says everything hurts and i'm like
listen
if you're laying in bed all day maybe
you have bed sores or you've become
soft from being inactive comfort comes
before style yes you've
you've gained a ton of weight this is a
this is a this is a painful cycle people
fall into
they start you know getting out of shape
gaining weight then they start feeling
bad about themselves
so instead of going out getting active
and reversing it they re retreat back
inside
she says everything feels like a chore
that's literally depression now to be
fair
college students do look like 12 year
olds all right that one i agree with
but i don't know are we going to talk
about that again she says you're always
annoyed af this is just like it's it's
sad millennial depression
and but listen here what i'm seeing from
this is if she's a creator if she's an
influencer
and she thinks this resonates with her
audience millennials got serious
problems it does so my
my girlfriend is a hair stylist and
every day in her chair she has an
endless stream of women between 25 and
55
coming into her chair and when you sit
down in a hair stylist chair it's sort
of like sitting down at the therapist
because you're not making direct eye
contact and you can just
just spill your guts and of course the
whole time she's just like oh yeah
uh-huh and she tells me that the women
all say the same thing every single one
that comes into her chair talks the same
way
so this gaining weight the world
what's causing that there's always sugar
sugar it's not just always sugar well
it's like the drug it's like more
addictive than hair sure i think but i
think i think we've got cultural
problems
so like you know looking at the grammys
for instance the ratings went way down i
bring this up cultural decay
people aren't looking forward to things
anymore there's nothing people
like look i think it might be the sugar
man i think that's over
that's an oversimplification super
simple but like okay every path of least
resistance right
everybody everybody is dealing with
crazy cultural problem right now
where we've got social media making
people depressed they want likes they're
desperate for it
but there's no actual community event
for them to go out to and that's what i
think is a big factor here
yes but what we need to look at is
whether or not the rates of anxiety and
depression were this high
in february of 2020 as they are now and
i would guess
that they they are i think i think they
are yeah i think that depression anxiety
among females especially was as it may
be higher
now i think it's i think but it was high
before corona
i i think it's fair to say depression
and anxiety are probably
very similar among men and women i think
i think it's probably just a lot of guys
who won't talk about it
i've been most depressed in life when i
was eating crappy
100 i used to eat like oats just
but buckets of oats honey sugar
and just felt like crap my eyes would be
all puffy my skin would get all pale
and i mean i cut that stuff out man it
just life got easier
i think it's a marketing pitch right now
too what's that mean
uh you know like recipes are all like
you're depressed not feeling good i'll
get you
here buy my brownie recipe or you know
like take this drug
join my thing buy my content buy this
shirt
it's super nordica right buy your comfy
pants
you know like it's it's a marketing
thing but why is it a marketing thing
because it resonates why does it
resonate
we could go back two weeks talk about
our other discussion which i won't get
into now but i do firmly believe that
those structural relationship issues
have led to this
you you've got a decline there was an
article talking about how young men
are becoming are staying virgins longer
and longer and longer
there's a lot of reasons for this but i
think when you
and and we can talk about all the
different correlations in in human
behavior
why millennials why are they so
what's what's up with the wokeness right
because i i did a segment about this a
couple of years ago i think one of the
big factors
in this you know for this woman why
they're depressed is a lack of purpose
in life we used to have purpose
you guys know what blue zones are you
know blue zones are yeah
parts around the world where if you live
there you eat the diet that's indigenous
there and you get the sunlight and air
you live to like 150 years old or
whatever that may be the issue blue
zones are areas where people live to be
over 100 and there's a there's a certain
combination of factors they found in all
these different places
you know one of the most important
things was purpose
i remember watching an interview where
there's like this 100 year old japanese
guy chopping wood
and like the woman's like why are you
why are you doing this shouldn't someone
else do this and he goes who's gonna do
it
and she's like well there's younger
people who can chop the woods like no no
i have to do it
otherwise no one else will and the
people need so what happens is
they they're they're they talk about how
at retirement it's the most common age
of death
when you retire from your job people
just lose purpose
you take a look at these millennials
they don't have purpose their purpose is
to post a picture of themselves that's
fake instagram reality that's what they
call it a fake photo themselves to ryan
maximize how many likes they can get
and it's making people depressed it's
not just the social media factor that's
making people depressed
it's that they have nothing to do with
their lives so we get one of two things
you get all the ultra woke people who
have filled the void in their hearts
with the world is racist you know oh we
we
we've got to occupy this zone for
justice we've got to go down here
and and and what shoot people is that
what you think is giving you purpose
well apparently they have nothing else
so when that white
suv pulled up in seattle they were like
this is my mission and they just unload
into it
it's because they have nothing to live
for on the other side what do you get
in cells in cells you get young men who
are angsty and angry who don't go out
who don't go for walks who don't
exercise
who feel completely defeated who feel
that they're they're too
ugly there's something wrong with them
and they'll never succeed
and jordan peterson you know there's a
reason why what he said resonated with a
lot of these young men
find the heaviest thing you can carry
and carry it he was basically saying
get out and do something so you have i
see this very much so not
every millennial many of them have
filled the void with fake purpose
activism and nonsensical threats to
their existence and the other half have
just
abandoned purpose and just play video
games all day and waste away
this is leading to mass depression in my
opinion but there's a lot of other
factors too
huge amount of factors but you're
absolutely right the the number one
issue is a loss of meaning
and part of that is because we've
diminished the value of nationalism
surviving for your country thriving for
your country not a thing
it's not cool to be a nationalist
anymore popularly
i mean even if i i think there could be
uh a global effort towards like the iss
or something or to going to mars
we don't have that either yeah there's
no where's like
you know we we land on the moon and it's
this big television broadcast look what
we're doing we're amazing and everybody
was like look how awesome we are it was
competition
but we don't we don't even have
cooperation between
like uh any goals there's no goal okay
even if you're even if people are like
it's about nationalism okay well you can
have a cooperative contest
a friendly competition between various
nations to help develop
the proper composite component whatever
for getting us a lightweight material
strong
flexible and finding a way to colonize
mars we don't have that space elevators
we don't have anything like that
we have some people who very much like
the idea and then we have a dominant
culture of posting fake pictures on the
internet
posting dumb videos complaining about
somebody for some reason
and then what do you get you get cats
against humanity saying they're gaining
tons of weight they'd rather go to sleep
everything hurts
they have a favorite spatula but
everything feels like a chore and
they're always annoyed
they're depressed okay this is a very
complex subject
and there's a lot of factors in it this
is all by design
eliminating meaning from your life is by
design
first and i'm not particularly religious
but they've destroyed your relationship
with god god
gave people meaning he did okay well
listen listen
religion also gave people community yes
they would show up to church they would
talk they would know who was there they
would know you know oh i can't wait till
to tell so and so about you know this or
that
it's all gone take away god
take away your nation take away your
community
take away your family hell
take away your identity as like
i'm just a dude not anymore not anymore
you know what there's no meaning by
design why so that you can have your ego
your sense of self and everything about
you obliterated
smashed into a million billion pieces
and then you can be
whatever they want you to be communist
socialist
anti-racist mostly the same thing
purchaser they want consumer they want
to sell you stuff
they want they want to break you down
not the capitalists
it's the communists that do that dude i
i want the documents in front of me
because i agree with you we've had james
lindsay was on last week talking about
it's like a
80 year old communist plot basically
yeah this has been going on since 1930s
look i i i talked to one of the leading
russian
the leading russian philosopher who
helped in the 80s and 90s
formulate the way to destroy america i
talked to him
directly and he admits
the whole point is to destroy meaning is
to destroy
barriers is to erase boundaries and
barriers that give you identity
and give you a place in the world if you
look out into the universe it's infinity
your brain explodes when you're
confronted with infinity the only way
that we can have sanity
is if you make barriers and boundaries
and identify who you are and have an
identity
and give yourself meaning all the
institutions that gave us meaning
gone corrupted universities churches
government
nationalism all of it gone it's all gone
all the sources of meaning in our life
are gone
it's by design and we need to build back
what's the
meaning the end result is people that
are too depressed too scared too
too anxious to fight back against
anything to be an individual
to even know what's right they get
turned into these mindless drone
foot soldiers that are like black lives
matter right on except they don't
understand what that really means
they don't realize that the fist they
hold up is actually the communism fist
yeah i'm not it's not even exaggeration
that black fist everyone sees
it was it was really interesting when i
saw the fist uh popping up everywhere
and people were calling it the black
lives matter first i never really
thought much about it but
well it's the it's the communist fist so
one on the ark so that's the same right
it signifies so uh for those that aren't
familiar
there's something called the was it the
fascists yeah that's the it's the bundle
of sticks wrapped around
wrapped around with a blade in the
middle some kind of weapon uh fascist or
however you pronounce it
and sticks uh
yeah the root the root of fascist is a
bundle of sticks is that funny is it a
bundle of sticks isn't there a word that
we're not allowed to say anymore that
also meant a bundle of sticks
because it represents that each
individual individual stick is weak but
together
bound together they are a strong and
powerful weapon the fist signifies
literally the same thing each individual
finger can be broken but when you
combine them you get a powerful fist
and so this symbol goes back i think 100
years too much of the communist
revolution stuff we saw in the early
1900s
and now black lives matter quite
literally uses the communist fist oh
there's communists
uh you can also get a our pillow i think
on tim look i'm gonna make a real quick
shameless plug here if you're a man and
you feel like you don't have any meaning
and your community has been obliterated
and you're not allowed to be a
nationalist and you've lost touch
we have an antidote for that we're
building intentional communities this is
this is the answer to the future
liminal order come check it out liminal
hypothesis i i don't i understand what
you're saying about nationalism but i
think it's just general community
yeah like people who lived in in texas
30 years ago didn't have the same
ideals as those who lived in new york
but they had a community that gave them
purpose
and then beyond that there was a shared
national identity and specific goals if
you go back to the 60s
fighting the cold war was important to
basically everybody in this country
today man you couldn't find unity to
stop china's concentration camps if you
tried
they argue about what the right approach
is nobody wants to to get on board with
any
any plan and we just kind of sit back
and let everything fall apart meanwhile
what are we complaining about cardi b
and candace owens we're going at it on
twitter i suppose well i think there is
an issue
there and how the fake me like how the
media manipulates the narrative and
you know we'll absolutely go after
candace owens for for criticizing what
we thought the grammys
it's interesting that our culture has
become
cancer our culture has become culture
war the culture war is our culture
what we are interested in talking about
in mainstream television is
shock content and hating each other cnn
what what is cnn's main goal what has it
been for four years
complaining about donald trump trump is
gone okay let's try tucker carlson
and it was really funny frank luntz the
famous pollster tweeted at brian stelter
when he tweeted this
maybe try covering the issues instead of
some guy
and then brian was like maybe you should
watch the full segment because no dude
talk about the issues
i'm not interested in any of these
individuals necessarily sure we can call
out bad behavior when it's particularly
egregious
but our culture is nothing now for the
most part other than
here's who i don't like meanwhile you
know china's culture is
we're expanding into the south china sea
we're building military bases on the
atolls we're building fake
we're building artificial islands to
hold weapons
and you know what's really scary donald
trump ordered what's called an elephant
walk
well i believe it was trump's trump
administration where we sent bombers and
fighters to guam
and we have them go along the runway to
show how powerful we are
and did you know that we were treated we
were treated our forces from guam
when they were supposed to be doing that
elephant walk to show how powerful we
are where do we treat you know why
because china's military capabilities
could have wiped out the entire fleet
before they could get off the ground
talk about a sign of weakness for the
united states now what do we get
wokeness in the military the chief
diversity officer to make sure that
everybody
is being treated properly gender neutral
testing and now all of a sudden
we gotta get rid of that because the
women aren't passing god have equal
outcomes
women can't get promoted if they can't
pass the physical exam therefore we
gotta change the physical physical exam
so they can pass more that's what we're
worried about in this country
bill maher said it and it is an
excellent quote we are a silly silly
people
china they're as serious as a prison
fight that's what he said
i think we we really need a second
coming of christ
because elon's not getting it done if
elon musk can
can engineer our our exposure to mars
and build
i am not technology it can prove i know
it can preserve our species he's the
engineer that can help us preserve
going to mars is going to hell it's not
enough like he can't if people don't
rally around elon we need
jesus like we need to be like hold on
hold on god back
after these associations yes sir mars is
not hell
what do you think the what do you think
the the colonists the early pilgrims and
colonists thought about land crash
landing
i'm being a bit exact i'm exaggerating
what do you think they thought about
getting on a boat for three months with
a deep with a one in five chance of
dying
to land on a shore where there's no food
no water no shelter nothing
first of all they believed that there
would be food and they believed that
they would bear water because they knew
they were going to be on earth
first of all and they knew how to hunt
and where they were living already they
were already fending off the land
i am not going to mars you there's
nothing you could say to convince me
i don't want to go to mars but guess
what so so
you're saying the people who left europe
to come to the new world
had the ability to farm and hunt yeah
dude so wouldn't the people going to
mars have the ability to use the
technology sent there beforehand to
produce food and water and shelter
i suppose if there's water and food and
sunlight okay temperatures
there's comparing mars to the new world
in the 1500s is insane
it's not insane it's insane people who
would be going to mars are going to have
technological advancements on their side
is there oxygen there yeah there will be
yes it's in the water under the surface
okay it's in the ice turn mars into
earth you got to melt the ice
and then i will go no there's no
magnetosphere i think that's maybe the
holes
maybe sounds terrible right
you don't understand the people who
don't understand yeah these big wooden
ships the technological advancements
that allowed them to actually make it
across the atlantic thousands of miles
these were very brave people no doubt
who didn't know what they were going to
encounter and there wasn't going to be
food or shelter in fact thanksgiving
they almost died because they had
nothing to eat and they were saved right
so you so what i'm saying is it is yeah
substantially harder to be a pioneer to
another planet
you need to go to mars the alternative
hypothesis around thanksgiving is is
like
look at us show off this abundance
of food by the way before we go to mars
we're going to be sending supplies and
technology
so that the people who finally arrive
will be able to build large eco-domes
with food and supplies that will last
them for years with consistent amounts
of supplies coming in okay i understand
a lot of people are scared of this
because it's a one-way trip for the most
part
and you may die on a red planet i'm not
saying it better be green by the time i
get it it's not ever going to be
it could be i thought that's what you
were just telling me that it was gonna
be green you can seed bomb it there's no
magnetosphere whatever prometheus
water on the planet because they can't
an accident there is it's just
it's just a light one there there's
there's there's no way to maintain an
atmosphere it's dissipating
are you trying to talk me into it or out
of it bro i'm trying to explain to you
that there's no atmosphere that we used
to be we used to have people on this
planet who are willing to
sacrifice in the name of of reaching new
heights
of challenging themselves and finding
freedom and now
now we have a bunch of people who
instead of saying i'm gonna move to the
middle of nowhere and build my own
building
do what i have to do they're saying i
want the government to regulate
all of the jobs i'm not religious at all
but i'm with you on that but not on
christ i mean i think that we need this
like this belief in
i don't know if it's god or what but
like this unified belief in in
the universe structure you know that
that jesus was one of the guys that was
like i'm tapped he tapped into it
the basis of spirituality is to get
outside of yourself
whether it's a belief in god an
afterlife
community service helping other people
doing charity work
get out of yourself our culture today is
designed around being in yourself
wallowing in yourself and presenting
yourself as the biggest
victim that there is in order to get to
the top of the victim
standings that's the problem with our
culture today bro people just need to go
play frisbee
we're talking about a lack of of self a
lack of well not a lack of self it's
nothing but the self we're talking about
a lack of
purpose meaning community friends goals
go outside bring a frisbee with you to
the park and say you wanna play frisbee
you wanna just throw a frisbee around
maybe hang out with some people it's
actually really fun and
they don't throw a ball back and forth
but people need to go outside
and actually do something instead people
are recoiling they're retreating they're
hiding
now i think i'll i'll tell you what i
think one of the biggest problems
problems we've got as a as a culture
certainly china doesn't have it
there their people in china they're
they're calling what china is doing
neo-colonialism
because the people in china are leaving
they're taking what money they have
they're moving to other countries
they're emigrating
and now we're seeing large chinese
communities emerging in many other
countries it's neo-colonialism
it's not happening because the chinese
government isn't is ordering people the
chinese communist party
is ordering people to go and take over
anything like that no no no
it's just people who are in a very
crowded country
trying to find a better life just like
we saw with europe hundreds of years ago
but now there's planes there's trains
there's boats and many of these people
have the resources
they find their way to another country
set up communities and they grow and
they work and i'll tell you this
the american dream is alive and well
there's just too many people in this
country too egotistical to actually work
towards it
when i worked for american eagle
airlines and america
it's american airlines regional uh
airline
there was a group that referred to
themselves as the filipino mafia
no joke that's what they called
themselves and it was a large group of
filipino immigrants who were working for
the for the airport
working for the airline and they all
basically
worked 14 or you know 16 hour days every
day
there was one guy he was like in his 50s
they forced him to take a two-week
vacation a two-week paid vacation
and he was freaking out and complaining
saying i refuse you can't make me do it
they said actually we legally are
required
to make you take a two-week vacation he
didn't want to do it because a one-week
vacation is only 40 hours paid
when he worked 80 hours a week and you
know why because he was
he came to this country he worked 80
hours a week and
every penny went into making his
children's lives
better this is a guy that was in the
philippines and said i'm going to move
to america and i am going to work my
skin to the
bone no matter what it takes for that
american dream and his dream
was to work for 10 bucks an hour every
single
day because he knew would make his
children's lives better
where's that at where are the people
today that are saying
i will do anything i can a lot of
immigrants who come to this country
absolutely believe that i've watched it
you look at the people who come from
china the united states what do they do
they cram their families into small
apartments that are cheap
they they work themselves to bone they
make money and they give their children
a better life
now we have a lot of people in this
country a lot of a lot of progressives
mind you yeah obviously i'm biased in
that regard who are just demanding the
government give to them
meanwhile they're the ones who are
claiming they're the party of immigrants
and it's like well why don't you
actually take some advice from them
and work hard to succeed that that's why
i i look at the mars thing
yeah i get it mars is difficult mars is
scary there are a lot of people who want
to go to mars i don't know if we need to
go to mars
it's necessarily i think a solution to
our problem i think maybe a space
station is probably better
and then maybe finding you know a
long-term vessel of some sort i don't
know how we do it our technology is not
there yet
a martian colony can be fantastic for
the development of new technologies to
make everyone's lives better
and the people who ultimately decide to
go there are going to be going on a very
dangerous journey where they will
probably die
the the likelihood of death might be
like one in five like it was for those
who went from europe
to the new world granted we have new
technology
and we'll have a lot of fail safe so
maybe it'll actually be a bit less but
boy will it be lonely
but these are the people who are saying
hey man i'm down to do it
now while we've got all these people
signing up for elon musk's mars trip
there was that mars one project what it
was called
and thousands of people like i want to
go to mars i want to go to mars and none
of them were
healthy enough to actually do it where
are the people
you live in new york city you live in
minneapolis and you're like man this is
terrible
antifa's taking over the government
they're getting funding now they're
shooting people not nonstop we're all
depressed
bro why don't you get up go outside
start planting some flowers start
planting some corn
why don't you like you know what you
know what i've been looking at for a
long time it's like
moving out to the middle of nowhere on
purpose to expand and to build something
because when i assume that doesn't work
you know what i do i don't go
this is why i hated working for other
companies you go to the boss and you're
like
hey i see this problem and they say too
bad i don't care i can't i can't do that
i can't sit there and look at a problem
that won't be solved so i'll say okay
i'm gonna leave
and then i'm gonna do it on my own
because if you don't know how to run
this system i'll figure it out for
myself
where are those people where are the
modern pioneers who are like i'm gonna
move to the middle of nowhere
start a company and revive this dying
town instead they're in their dying
towns complaining to the government to
do more to protect their jobs
and it's both the left and the right i
think they exist but they're drowned out
in a sea of noise
especially online with when everyone has
their own no
anybody at journal anybody online who
believes that they can do it
is doing it online is the land of the
icants
what i have found interesting is that
our country used to be
a country of i can i can sail across the
atlantic and start a new life
i can explore the west coast go to
oregon go to the seattle
washington state i can do that you mean
i can walk there i can
didn't have access to a newspaper to
tell everyone how you couldn't do it you
just didn't have access to
now you got twitter for free and now
you're playing but the problem the
problem is is that the american
spirit the american dream if there is
actually one american dream is i can
yeah all these other folks right now
that we're talking about these are the i
can't
when did the american dream go from like
working hard to
just like being handed a million bucks
1970 when nixon took us off the gold
standard no
fiat currency okay come on it's when the
communists have
infiltrated american institutions and
have pumped us awful the notion
that the government is supposed to give
us everything when was that
starting in the 50s and the 60s dude it
used
it used to be mccarthy was right
the american dream actually was upward
mobility
there are certain countries where you're
poor you'll always be poor because
you're not a noble you're not landed
gentry you're not a king it's never
going to happen
you come to america and you could flick
off the president you could see you
could see the president walking by and
go hey president
f.u and they can't do anything about it
the american dream was that you could be
gutter trash
and grow up to be a millionaire as long
as you worked hard
and figured it out and that still exists
the problem is it still exists it
happens every day
and at some point millennials especially
figured the american dream was
i do as i'm told i take out massive
loans
i go to college and then i'll be rich it
could have been
the rockefeller movement like he
monopolized and
the education industry and kind of
destroyed people's will to i never went
to business school i didn't know how to
run a business i don't know how to sign
a check until i was 19 years old
i didn't write a check isn't that insane
i never wrote a check
let me tell you something let me say
something yes i understand what you're
saying jack about communism
and infiltrating schools and all that
stuff and i've heard a lot about it we
know that china has an interest in
promoting this because
the chinese accounts on twitter this is
what james lindsay was saying they used
to they used to mock the baitswa
the white left that's their worst
baitswa all of a sudden they started
supporting them saying yeah america's
racist because they realized it was
weakening the country but i'll tell you
something
in my experience my anecdotal uh my
personal world view my lived experience
my lived your viewpoint my personal
point of view
my family i hear i always would hear
these stories growing up about how
someone my family knew was making six
figures
because they went to college and that's
why you have to go to college to get a
good job
and i said not interested and then what
i realized later in life was that
a lot of these people after world war ii
the boomers right they had high school
educations
and they were feeding their family three
kids and a wife just on their high
school education
they made it work granted they didn't
have the same level of technology or
comfort as we did
so you know standard of living was
particularly different
but with the high school education alone
i read about how
the boomer generation people with high
school educations
they were managers at companies they had
jobs they weren't making six figures
they made the false assumption that the
money
came because of the college degree
however
if you grew up at a time where you
didn't need a college degree to be to
succeed and feed your family
but you decided to pursue your passion
what was really happening is that those
were who are most passionate and driven
towards a certain goal decided to go to
college
college was incidental it's a spurious
correlation
the actual correlation is those who are
willing to work hard to attain or
achieve some goal and those who are not
what happens then when your entire
society starts telling all the young
people
college is the key take out 40 50 60 000
of loans you'll never pay back in a
lifetime you end up with a bunch of
angry
indebted serfs can't find work
and think the american dream was
stripped from them well they were lied
to for sure
by society went astray but these are
people who
need to be taught how hard work can give
you the american dream
the only problem is the hard work they
worked towards was a trap
they dug themselves into a massive hole
generated tons of debt
because they were dumb 18 year olds who
didn't know better and because
i blame the older generation stripping
the value
extracting what they can and then we get
financial crisis
chaos and everything's falling apart so
forgive me if i'm a millennial blaming
the older generations but i
look we inherited this stuff from you so
it's not on me
you're a gen xer right represent you get
a free pass
i'm gen x as it gets tim a lot of what
you said is absolutely right
the people that made the most of a
college degree were going to make the
most of life
anyway when they didn't need one though
right the point is
if society tells you you don't need to
go to college and you go yeah but i want
to because i really want to study this
thing
well it's no surprise that this
passionate driven individual became
successful
but you get a bunch of people who are
like you know i remember when i was 18
and they're like you got to go to school
and i'm like for what
what do you like doing i don't know well
how about music you play music
i guess so when i was going to be an 18
year old going like oh
and then but but draining tens of
thousands of dollars in debt
that's the stupidest idea i was like i'm
not gonna do that's dumb i don't wanna
owe anybody money
i'd rather just like sleep on a couch
and go skating
so it worked out for me i don't got any
debt a lot of people i do have that
right that still worked out for me
because i wanted to i wanted to go i
wanted to study acting
and it was worth every penny of it not
for everybody most people change their
majors
yeah and end up not getting a job in
their field you got to want it you got
to be good at it you got to be dedicated
to it
you got to live it breathe it focus on
it every second of every day
it is your life that is what you are
tell you what else it's doing the
money's subsidiary
you want to know what else college did
you want to know what else it did jack
it took kids out of their communities
and sent them to far away lands
and then all of a sudden their ties to
the community were fractured
so now you had people growing up and
they weren't going to the water cooler
they weren't going to the churches
maybe they're not religious they weren't
going to the community centers
they weren't engaging in local activism
or local journalism or local politics
they moved away maybe there's a good
thing in that but ultimately it means
our community started breaking apart and
now one of the biggest problems we have
is people are replacing their real
communities with fake online communities
often with sock puppet accounts
and they're looking for some kind of
gratification from online strangers who
have cat avatar profiles or something
or a cat cat anime pictures on their
twitter account that's current but the
future is actually using the internet to
find
real communities 100 it's happening
i'm doing it i won't pitch it anymore
you guys we got to bring people to the
real world
that's absolutely a hundred percent tim
you're talking about things that have
been in play for
decades and decades and decades and
decades now
yeah i mean it's true these ideas were
seriously implanted in our brains back
in the 50s and the 60s and they've now
made their way through the institutions
to the point now where we are a
sick culture of victims who rank
themselves according to how aggrieved
they are not according to how successful
or accomplished they are or how realized
actualized that they are it's actually a
detriment to be successful
right because that's evidence that
you're part of the white supremacy
well that's that's what they said to me
when uh when i was at occupy wall street
before i got any recognition i had all
these people saying like see look at you
man you know
you dropped out of high school and like
you're a smart guy you should be very
successful but the system doesn't allow
it you know
you come from a mixed family and it's
very obvious how it's holding you back
and then all of a sudden i'm featured in
time magazine i'm featured on all these
websites and you know they said then
tim pool is white and he was born with a
silver spoon in his mouth
more or less story don't listen to other
people in this re
and this the moral perhaps and the gist
of the story is
if you succeed they will accuse you of
being privileged and
always having been privileged because
the idea of hard work doesn't exist to
them
exactly because if you succeed
that means that the only reason they're
not succeeding because they didn't try
yep and that is and that's why the
asians are gonna get crushed by the
blacks in this new culture scenario
that's why they're trying to make it
look like there's white on asian
violence happening all over the universe
when there really isn't
this is one of the most the real issue
is that the asian
immigrants are making african-american
indigenous people
look bad do you think that's why the
violence is happening
no that that's the violence is what it
is that guy shot up a bunch of
hookers yeah that was sex related okay
but this idea well we don't know that's
true actually
it doesn't it doesn't matter the point
is is that it's not some white
supremacist going on a rampage trying to
kill a bunch of asian ladies
like come on so what's happening here is
that
the the the the crt folks and the
african-american victim community that
wants to be victims not all of them the
specific community
are saying that we live in an oppressive
society that keeps minorities down
well guess what all these asian folks
are coming from all over not just
far east asia or southeast asia or india
asia but all of those asia parts
they're coming to the united states and
they're out earning white dudes yeah
this actually surprised me because i
i didn't realize filipinos actually have
some of the highest incomes in the
united states yeah
dude it's the it's it's indian folks
come
asian folks come to united states make
more money than white people why
because it's a meritocratic system if
you're good at something you get paid
for it
you can be tim pool drop out of high
school
not go to college become a you know many
thousand there
here living in in wherever we are but
the reason that this conflict is going
to come between the blacks and asians is
because
the asians are just proving the thesis
of black lives matter
false it's not a race thing it's
it is not going to be black people
versus asian people it is going to be
woke people versus asian people sorry
you're right
yeah it's so like alan west sitting here
the other day amen
amen i'm sorry all those comments were
meant to say
the crt you know social justice
black lives matter folks that are
pitching they're mostly white the
fine all of them are pitching the black
victimhood narrative
yeah that all black suffering is a
result of white systems of oppression
which i heard
chanted over and over again but bro
they're not saying just black people
they're saying a hierarchy of different
races are oppressed by white people
they used to claim that it was asian
people on top now
after this shooting they're saying
asians are actually oppressed again
so it's it's not about any one race it
is about manipulative
extremist dogmatic cultists who will who
will use whatever narrative they have to
to gain power
sometimes they'll talk about black lives
matter but they'll use the communist
fist as their symbol
sometimes they'll blame asians because
you've got that one woman i'm not going
to say her name but james lindsey's been
tweeting up a storm about her where she
was like well you see
the asians who came here chose to come
here in the early you know
early american history they weren't
forced to do it then after this wave of
violence
they say now they're being now she's
tweeting they were forced to come here
actually it was indentured servitude
blah blah it's like oh okay
you never cared about these people you
manipulate these people
it doesn't matter if you're asian latino
hispanic black or whatever
all they want to do is hit one group
against the other to gain power
so they're going to use victimhood amen
and they're going to say
these people are oppressing us and it's
funny they accused trump of being the
demagogue
they said he was the one who was
vilifying different groups of people
sure there were certain instances where
trump said some things like you know he
wanted to ban all muslims
donald trump literally said that he was
calling for a ban on muslims until they
can figure things out
eventually what they called the muslim
ban came to include a couple other
countries like venezuela north korea so
it wasn't
exclusively a muslim ban or contain all
the muslim countries
right it didn't it didn't include saudi
arabia indonesia right
america muslims the point was donald
trump certainly had his bombastic
demagoguery type language but they are
built upon it and have been for a decade
trump was a response to it not the
creation of it amen when they kept
coming out in the early you know to that
late 2009 early 2010s
screaming about white privilege racism
systemic racism white people
and you can see in in the alexis nexus
data the hockey stick of the new york
times just
screaming about white privilege then you
got what they were calling the white
lash a backlash but white people were
now saying enough of this already
the funny thing is we were taught
growing up
segregation is wrong people should be
treated equally it was the dream of dr
king that all people would be treated
based on the content of their character
not the color of their skin
and which party is fighting that tooth
and nail
the democratic party joe biden's
department of education
just rescinded a rule that said
racial affinity groups was
discriminatory that rule's gone now that
was a trump rule trump said you can't do
this you can't separate people at
schools based on race
biden's administration no no you can do
that again congratulations columbia
university just said graduations by
race that's right by race
now what's funny is at the end of the
day you're right there's going to be one
small group of people over here the woke
and there's going to be a huge coalition
of diversity
over here opposing woke and in fact the
uh opposing racial justice people
will be more diverse than the group
saying that they're you know the woke
folks and the irony is
it's not gonna be african-americans
in the middle of that it may end up
amanda being black trans women or
whatever but
but truly all of this is is suburban
white yes liberal women that's right
this entire thing is about suburban
white liberal women their guilt their
their
interest in destroying the patriarchy
they're lying supinely
on the ground begging for acceptance and
forgiveness
and they're willing to throw their
entire country away just so that they
won't be called a racist when they
haven't been one
they aren't one and they've just taken
this identity
on for themselves uh i did an interview
with arthur millick the head of the
center for the american way of life in
washington to see a claremont
east operation and he pointed out
that even the ancient texts the classics
they talk about the demise of a society
is when it's
run on the whim and fancy of single
women
that is what we have today the entire
nation
all of our political discourse all this
woke crap all this everything
is based on trying to appease the this
power of
single white liberal women and you know
what's funny half of
guys are just doing what those women
tell them of course because what do they
want they want the women
right so they're just saying so they'll
do whatever yeah
these boys need some chad immunity i got
chad immunity for days if you want to
quarantine a a vaccine i got it for you
chad immunity
look it up yeah i think that there
look i think that's one of the issues i
think we're facing a ton of a ton of
problems we've been facing for a long
time and one of the things i bring up
when was the last time a christmas song
was written right it's a typical
question
uh something i bring up quite a bit all
i want for christmas is you by
mariah carey i guess in the 90s we
listen to music from the 50s on
christmas
that's a classic yeah but at a certain
point like that was new okay
so
they wrote these songs they wrote songs
they wrote jingle bell rock
and it was new and everyone loved it and
we all danced and sang together
every year since then we'd play the same
songs over and over and over again no
one writing anything new
no one creating no one developing
american culture
it's become stagnant reboot remakes
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
reboot spider-man for the fifth time
we're gonna we're gonna reboot this
comic book this movie we're gonna remake
groundhog day we're gonna remake
whatever else they keep doing it i saw
that
where's the new where's the new strongly
opposed to remaking groundhog day
where's the new stuff it's this show so
listen listen man you should you want to
use
stuff for sure okay
yes you want to talk about the woke how
their
all the problems they're bringing i got
to stop and say at a certain point
you know we had a great i know a lot of
people didn't like rucka but he asked a
good question
okay you're complaining about wokeness
what are you offering in exchange yeah
exactly
and i said classical liberalism and he
said okay we had a conversation from
there but i'm gonna stop right there and
go back to the culture question not the
not the political question
if we complain about they're making woke
captain america right
the new captain america is an lgbtq
activist they're saying i don't care if
you like that
then you can buy the comic you know when
i see all these people saying like oh
you know it's dumb that they're changing
all these things
we're angry by it my response is make
new characters
for these communities don't give them
hand-me-downs however if marvel
wants to make captain america an lgbtq
activist that's fine i'm happy for the
people who like that character it's none
of my business i just won't buy it
because i'm i'm not saying i refuse to
buy because i'm mad no i just won't buy
it so i probably don't care all that
much about reading that story but i'll
tell you this
where are you to make your own comic
where are you to make your own
new tv show or video game
how many people sit back and complain
why aren't they making the games that i
like in the movies i like i'm like i
don't know why aren't you making them so
we can sit here and complain about the
woke and i think it's merited
but at a certain point we've complained
about ourselves for not doing enough not
making our own things our own culture
amen shout out daily wire and we've been
talking about doing new cultural stuff
too
we're a small company we haven't many
people but we are actively working and
trying to figure out how to grow and
expand and create new brands
make new new uh entertainment new
fiction new nonfiction
we're talking about doing this
paranormal podcast trying to figure out
it's very difficult
because you know i'm just one person we
got a small handful of people but at a
certain point
you got to make stuff you got to build
your own house you got to move and start
your own farm you got to start your own
data
data server farm you got to start your
own web hosting companies
it's happening you know we see what gaap
is doing but at a certain point
you got to stop complaining that other
people
don't agree with you and won't give you
what you want well i can absolutely
agree it is a problem for our society
when big tech is censoring people
because they have a monopoly on the
political discourse space
at a certain point you must take control
and do the work yourself because no one
is coming to save you
most all people are consumers
they're not even built to be creators
they're not interested in being creators
they don't want to be artists they're
too busy
they're working they're trying to
survive they come home they want to
consume
it's okay it's normal so when somebody
who's a consumer complains that they're
not be given the things that they want
that's a valid complaint the people you
should be complaining to talking to
pointing their fingers at are people who
are creators and get them moving in the
right direction
hold on complaining hold on one second
yes
but what about the people who sit around
playing video games all day what about
the people who are like
you know i lost my job or haven't worked
since covid did you write a book
you start drawing pictures they're
consumers they're consumers consumers
it's okay to be a consumer most people
are consumers most people are not
creators
i think that what you're doing is
potentially like applying the solution
that you see
is as possible in front of you and
demanding it of everybody else i don't
know that that's necessarily
possible and so what how do consumers
contribute to society
to merit consuming products made by
other people
do they have jobs of course so they're
making something
well they're cogs in a big thing they're
cogs in the machine they're pushing
papers you want doing spreadsheets
you're flipping burgers you talk about
decades of conditioning
stripping away the american spirit i
will not tolerate
personally and someone saying well i'm
just someone who who works a menial job
so i can come and play video games i'm
like nah
let's talk about conditioning who told
you to think that way how come no one
ever said why don't you draw a picture
start with a stick man
maybe in a few months we'll be drawing
anime or something why don't you make
something you can take little rocks and
you can you can make little little
macaroni art and sell it on the street
you can take a guitar learn three chords
play several top 40 songs maybe four
chords
and then you can busk in the street and
make money on your own amen
it is it to take away people's
independence and ability to create and
be independent thinkers
they wanted you in the machine they
wanted the bell ringing in grade school
to teach you how to work in a factory
now you're an adult now the system is in
decay what are you going to do
you can also be a consumer and a creator
in different
phases like i've gone through heavy
creation phases where that was all i did
and then i
go go back into my consumer phase for
like two years and then back into
creation phase for three months and then
so it maybe we should change your brain
space everyone
should be producing at a slightly higher
rate than they are consuming
that that that is extremely important
for expansion for growth survival
and it doesn't need to be as greta
tunberg said
this fairy tale of endless economic
growth
there can be endless economic growth
because we have digital and virtual
spaces
you can create things that are abstract
with the nft you know non-fungible
tokens now people are making art that
exist in the blockchain
it's a lot of things that you can do
that won't create something physical
you can write a song you can sing a song
you can record that song you create
information
you can do you can work on math you can
develop new ideas and new technologies
methodologies or at the very least
you can stop being a consumer in these
cities and maybe
go on to the middle of nowhere save up a
little bit of money to buy a small plot
of land literally in the middle of
nowhere dig your own well build your own
house because at what point
i don't i don't know when it happened
but people started saying the government
owes me
even conservatives say it even
conservatives the government owes me
the government should force these
companies you know uh not to do certain
things
i agree with that i agree with that i
agree with regulation
but i also recognize at a certain point
you have to be responsible for what you
truly want
and you can't expect someone to do it
for you i certainly think
there are regulations and they're like
you know i'm a fan of
you know border control ending these
free trade agreements
but i also think if it doesn't come to
you then you have to decide when you are
going to take the reins
and do the work to make it come to you
that might mean running for office
that might mean having a peaceful
protest i'm so into it dude let's run
for office
i'm not doing that get out of here you
want to run for office go ahead you do
it
i might have to for oh yeah run for
congress no i'd run for president
people need to take responsibility for
their lives man
man you're not gonna hear any pushback
from me on that personal responsibility
accountability auto regulation
independent thinking
making your own way owning your own s
yes that is the way this is the way
no question about it if you want to talk
about somebody busking and
there's a difference between hustling
and creating
that's what i'm trying distinction i'm
trying to make creating
tim you're a creator i'm a creator we're
creating we're creating art
we're creating journalism we're creating
media
this is it you want to know what's next
where is it what's the replace
this is literally it i've been on the
show with a million people watching the
show
this is literally it and it's not only
just like the underground
of it this is the like one step down
from mass media level in the united
states
there but there is there is a breaking
point we're experiencing where
this might be the new big thing yet to
us
is there ever going to be a big network
show
you know like when you would watch
walter cronkite or whatever no there's
not because there was three channels
then
exactly that's it so what's happening is
as our ability to
to source information fractures
american unified culture will cease to
exist amen amen there's huge chapters in
my book democrats are deplorable all
about this very element right here about
uh
liberating the means of communication i
used marxist language to describe what
happened
we've liberated the means of
communication instead of one person
talking to many
we have many talking to many and in
doing so we've created and injected a
number of new narratives
national narratives personal and
narratives
and now we have no cohesion because
walter cronkite used to sit there and
tell us all how to feel
that's right do you think religion is
necessary
yes i'm not even religious
yes we live in a christian society
that's true
and we we mentioned this the other day i
think i mentioned it to alan west that
people like bill maher he doesn't
realize that his values are actually
rooted in judeo-christian values
correct and he thinks he's a secular
atheist and
his morals aren't defined by the bible
and it's like bro they are
they are they literally are you don't
understand that the fifth amendment
in the fifth amendment the right to a
trial by jury a speedy trial the right
to remain silent all that stuff
that comes partly from blackstone's
formulation when he said it is better
that 10 guilty persons escaped than one
innocent person suffer
benjamin franklin said it's better that
a hundred guilty persons escaped than
one innocent person suffer
that came from the story of sodom and
gomorrah that god said for if there is
but one righteous person i will not
destroy this city
these ideas have existed for a very very
long time there are certain cultures
that don't
share that notion take a look at china's
history and their religion
they're an authoritarian communist sort
of communist nation
they don't have the same ideas about
innocent until proven guilty
you can take a look at some i am not
saying that every country that has ever
practiced this religion has
held these values certainly there have
been authoritarian nations that have
been
christian i'm saying that when we look
to these values
they have a root in judeo-christian
values a hundred percent
there was there i mean hammurabi you
ever heard of this
rabbi's code right they had a whole
entire
moral and legal framework for their
entire civilization
that's got nothing to do with what we
got going on yeah nothing
so bill maher sitting there in his
jacuzzi with his hookers and his cocaine
and his weed as he admits
thinks that he's an atheist who just
came up with these ideas of these values
that somehow they're universal they're
not universal first of all
entire civilizations have lived and
flourished and failed
eventually without these values and
without this uh the these
norms and here we are this is the most
successful culture
in the world ever based on christians
here's for a new religion here's what
well we have it it's called critical
race there it's called
a theory a good one sure here's what
here's what
you know bill maher thinks he looks to
backwards and confused
and poorly translated versions of
religion and then says see it's a bad
thing
and i use bill maher as an example
because i was just complimenting the guy
right
there are a lot of people who look to
religion and say here are all these bad
things and it's like okay well
what about all the good things i'm not a
religious person i i am not
theistic in any sense of you know these
religious texts or anything
anything like that anything like that
but i certainly think
you can find good ideas in every single
religious text okay obviously
every single i'm just being you know
hyperbolic but for the most part
you'll look at these religions and you
will find there's probably something
good
in them maybe not enough maybe it's 51
bad 49 good okay well then take the good
stuff and get rid of the bad stuff
that's what we've done here in the
united states there was a lot of really
bad stuff
well we started to get rid of all that
bad stuff and keep all the good stuff
that turns into sections of the bill of
rights
first of all the first amount the right
to practice your religion and then you
have
the right to you know trial by jury
innocent until proven guilty
and that is rooted that that's just a
fact it's rooted in
judeo-christian values in the story of
sodom and gomorrah i was like reading
about this and i was
actually really just impressed
when i read about i started researching
blackstone's formulation
why did he come up with the idea and the
history of it that's right religion
so it's not absolute i don't think you
need it but that's why i'm saying
when you asked if religion was necessary
i kind of went i don't know about
religion
we're finding out right now but you
don't need religion you need
shared a shared moral framework and what
many
what many that that's what it is no a
religion is like i i have faith in the
lord
or a lot of them is a cult like i have
faith in this guy that was telling me
about the lord
right you need a shared moral framework
okay religion is is
okay where does your moral framework
come from in the united states our moral
framework is judeo-christian
taoism not every single nation that has
been successful has a
judeo-christian moral framework but they
do share a moral framework
some moral frameworks are really really
awful and they're really nasty
based on our standards but that's the
point i'm saying bill maher's moral
framework is rooted in an american
judeo-christian moral framework this is
this country is not in my opinion
founded to be expressly a christian
nation but it was overwhelmingly
christian people
who created it it's christian in its
form and function
yes but not what i mean is there's no
state religion
there's not right they avoided making a
state religion by
baking the religion into the structure
of the government
well i i think what you're basically
saying is they took the moral framework
of the religion and and
structured it into government but it
left out a lot of the things they didn't
like
yeah they're like hey you can be here
and not be christian but by the way all
of our laws our rules our regulations
our morals the structure
how you're gonna live your life it's
christian are the evolution
of a judeo-christian moral framework now
you have secular individuals who don't
believe in god and don't believe in the
bible
and don't realize their moral framework
is rooted in an american culture that
was very religious and
look man look tim i want to go back to
what you were saying before
we don't have we want to go to mars
let's give us meaning
oh we need a we need the cold war we
need meaning
what you're looking for is something
bigger than yourself
that's right a mission not just a
mission because missions
end where do you think god came from
aside from actually being the creator of
the universe if that's what you believe
it is the need for a persistent
source of meaning outside of yourself
that will not be seasonal that does not
go away once the cold war is over
does not go away once we integrate with
the aliens
that does not go away when manifest
destiny is completed
you need a consistent and eternal sense
of meaning that is
outside of yourself so you don't get
lost in your own brain and turn into a
freaking victim
and sit around and say where's my stuff
i don't think missions have to end
like missionaries that's their life is
the mission and
the the pro the uh enterprise the uss
enterprise
that was it the naval ship persistent
mission good board
but it could come to an end it could but
it's not supposed to
because the infinite infinite universe
created by god that they're exploring
yes oh bro they're not exploring the
universe they're exploring a one
quadrant of the galaxy
thank you for uh i walked into the tim
compound today and what's playing
star trek next generation hold on hold
on a minute
the episode that was playing the hour
before was the
there are four lights tim i want to make
it there are four lights straight but i
don't know in response to
all this nonsense right now that you've
been spewing i'm four lighting it right
now four lights you're the guy that
would say four lights for those that
don't know this winston
listen listen let's talk about shared
shared culture
when i was a little kid i remember
sitting on my couch my dad was watching
star trek star trek the next generation
i understood very little of it there's a
reason why i love that show
and it's because of the philosophy and
the storytelling
and let me explain to all of you who
don't understand the holodeck let me
explain to all of you who don't
understand what it means when you say
there are four lights
captain jean-luc picard was captured
by enemies and he was being tortured
mercilessly
and the man torturing him had four
lights above him
and he asked captain picard how many
lights are there and picard said
there are four and then he presses a
button activating a torture device and
says you're mistaken
there are five lights and no matter how
hard he tried to
force captain picard to say something
that was not true
picard would not do it i know a lot of
people are like star trek's a silly
thing it's a sci-fi show no
you know what i learned growing up
seeing stories like that
there will never be a moment in my life
where you come to me and tell me to say
something that is not true
and i will say it i will look you in the
eyes and say there are four lights
when you come to me with your stupid
fake news garbage
and you say we will ban you we will
destroy you we will take your income we
will take your life
say there are five lights or else i'll
look you in the eyes and say
there are four lights that's what star
trek's about it seems like that show was
brilliant
and that was a show made by americans in
the 90s actually 1989
and that was the value being instilled
in people at that time and i grew up
with shows like that
today they have dogmatic cult-like
garbage
they are instilling into people and they
are ruining the classically liberal
defiant individualistic content that
taught us to be good people
to respect one another now they're
telling us the opposite
now colleges are segregating people
based on race when star trek was the
show
that they say had the first interracial
kiss apparently that may be a myth
but it did and it was important and
there was this really famous story i
read
about the woman who played captain uhura
on on star trek
when she was speaking with dr king i
don't know if the story is true i read
it somewhere
and maybe it was dr king maybe i'm
thinking the story way wrong and she
didn't want to be on the show and he
said you are
fourth in command to a federation
starship you do not quit that show
think about the message being sent to
little kids about what you represent
amazing that was star trek where are we
today
it's almost as if we've been occupied by
a virus that seeks our own destruction
the borg
a hundred percent were our nation's
infected with the virus that seeks to
kill the host the struggle session
this whole thing that's this this is the
struggle session
was going through a struggle session
this feels like a struggle since then
at the end of the episode picard was
asked was told by the guy torturing him
he said you can choose to live in pain
and suffering
or you can be comfortable comfortable
clothes and all the women
your heart's content and he says what
must i do and he say
tell me how many lights there are and
picard is looking
and that's when the other guards come in
to release picard and give him back to
the federation
at the end of the episode he's talking
to the counselor and he says
i would have said anything and i
actually believed
there were five lights yeah nobody's
perfect because torture does that to you
but but it's it's amazing i wonder what
inspired these writers when they write
these brilliant things well that's 1984
dude that's like a scene right out of
1980 right absolutely yeah
i think about shows like you know
futurama
have you ever seen jurassic park that's
what it was called and it was
it was an episode about you know fry and
his dog gets fossilized and he decides
whether or not he's gonna bring his dog
back
or there was also the episode about
fry's brother who kept stealing
his his ideas and his moves
talk about amazing writing an amazing
show so the character fry
talks about how he's a seven-leaf clover
and it gave him all the luck in the
world
but his brother yanzi kept stealing
everything from him he then learns
because it's a
future arms about a guy who travels a
thousand years in the future that a guy
named philip j fry who looks just like
his brother
was taking all his dreams going to mars
being in a rock band and he had a seven
leaf clove clover
at the end of the episode when he goes
to rob the grave of what he thinks is
his brother who stole everything
he learns that it was actually his
nephew that his brother
named after him because his brother
loved him what happened to shows like
that
this amazing writing where you're
watching this dumb comedy show
and you end up crying afterwards with
that episode and the episode jurassic
park
what happened to shows like star trek
even deep space nine was also amazing
profound writing now we have
transformers godzilla versus you know
king kong i get it we've probably had
movies like this in the past
yeah but i'm saying it's cultural decay
i mean even scrubs would get you yeah
riley's also good it's flooded the
industry's flooded so they have to like
do these beacons of light in the sense
of like let's do a reboot that
everyone's gonna put their eyes on
in 1989 it was like five twelve channels
you know
one production company that or like you
know a small segment of production
companies that could pick what got seen
i love marvel movies but there is not a
single marvel movie
and probably i don't know maybe i'm
wrong but on top of my head i don't
think i can name a movie in the past
five years
that gives me the same sense of like awe
and emotion that i get from like i think
the episode of star trek was called the
make of a man
when data the android was on trial and
they're trying to determine whether or
not he was a sentient living being with
full rights
and they talk about what makes a person
a person amazing
this is just amazing roddenberry was was
he still his wife also
was or she was in the show roddenberry
was he still involved with the writing
of
in the next generation i'm pretty sure
next generation was high quality i
remember watching it but
i watched i watched all the episodes
what what are we leaving for our kids
right
so that so i'm gonna throw to the
grammys now and actually say
to candace owens she's right i look at
that story about star trek and captain
uhura a black woman who was fourth in
command to into it to
the flagship of the of the federation
and it's a piece of fiction and it's
it's silly and everything but think
about what that means as a culture of
what we're telling our kids
that you can be the best of the best the
top highest ranking or one of them
now it's cardi b on a giant bed
jumping up and down on a song called
whap we're getting trouble on youtube
we've even tell you the name of it i
can't
even
how demoralized i am with that with that
grammy
performance with the whole cardi b
phenomenon with this
i can't i can't so did you just say that
youtube is more conservative
definitely than the no no legacy media
yeah absolutely
look i i don't care if cardi b wants to
do those dances okay that's fascinating
assessment
i mean i agree with you but it's just
it's fascinating to think that
culturally
they will censor whatever wap means
and yet you blast it out over the
airwaves
on the grammys now listen i am not
offended at all in any
way by the web performance i really
don't care
in the sense that if you want to have
your own show and you want to do that
by all means go and do it i'm just not
going to watch it much like the lgbtq
captain america
i'm glad you guys get your presentation
i think it's important
i'm happy you guys have a comic you're
you're enjoying me personally
i'm not gonna buy it i don't like mint
ice cream i don't like chocolate chip
mint i think mint is gross
i don't want to take it away from
anybody else i'm not offended by it i
just won't buy it
so the grammys can do their show and i'm
not going to watch it
but my criticism is that what do we then
share
as a mass culture where we all actually
say this is something that inspires us
and it makes us feel better oh yeah
that's gone
social cohesion is gone the top-down
one-to-many model of communication and
social cohesion
gone forever the only thing at this
point now that's going to bring
total cohesion is a return
my boy michael millerman knows what i
mean when i say return what does that
mean
return not everything old is bad and not
everything new is good
and and it's true yeah i think it's
funny i was taking these political tests
you know like the eight values and like
the political compass
my political compass test man i am
further left and further libertarian
than i've ever been
reading like through these tests but you
know what i realized the political
compass test is outdated
it doesn't ask anything about the modern
culture war the modern left or right
it asks you like how do you feel about
progressive taxes and like multinational
corporations so i'm like that doesn't
matter
but i was taking these tests and i was
just looking at some of these questions
and it's it's very interpretable
i guess what i'm trying to say is when
we try to understand someone's politics
you could ask someone a question like do
you think
major corporations have an advantage in
their ability to move quickly
and execute plans quickly no i i didn't
ask you if you thought it was good or
bad
oh i just think the answer to that
question is no do you don't think
corporations have an advantage over
moving quickly absolutely not that's the
biggest downfall over the government
oh over the government yes they can move
more quickly than the government i'm not
saying you like it and
that's what happens people end up
looking at you know these political
compass tests and political tests and
it's like no the only question dividing
us politically and will be eventually we
will all be sorted by this 100 percent
is do you believe
in essentialism or do you believe in the
blank slate that's going to be the final
dividing line
divine to find those things essentialism
that we are
an act who we are based on our biology
our hormones our size our strength
that you can't disconnect biology from
the way you behave and culture etc and
blank slate is that you're born with
nothing constructivism and you are
injected
with all the things that you believe and
all of your interests and all of your
desires and all of your capabilities and
all of your aptitudes
so let me we can pull this up i took the
eight values test and it ranks me as a
pragmatist
that says politics objectively boils
down to looking at where the problems
are and trying to solve them according
to the means available
but the interesting thing about this
when you're trying to figure out
someone's left or right you can't
anymore why
well i'm a progressive it says 69
progressive 19 kind of middle and then a
very tiny fraction conservative
i'm for 64 rehabilitative justice
man sounds like i'd fit right with a lot
of these progressives the only problem
i'm a 57 essentialist wait wait
rehabilitative justice is totally
different than restorative justice
right but the so that's that's critical
race collectivist stuff
yeah right so when the progressives talk
about
rehabilitation versus well at least they
used to that's why i'm saying
it doesn't apply anymore when you look
at the left and the right here's really
funny when you look at my
my my test 57 capitalism
but 69 progressive and they'll tell
they'll tell you people like me don't
exist
but i'm 57 essentialist meaning
collective constructivism
where you think everything's a construct
is is non-existent on my eight values
test
and then international and national are
fairly balanced revolution and reform
fairly balanced
ecology and production balanced
regulation and laissez faire balanced
the core issues for me are essentialism
or i should say this the big debate as
you pointed out right now
in politics in culture is constructivism
versus essentialism
that's what defines you as left or right
i suppose 100
and in fact that's the main thesis of my
book democrats are deplorable
is that our political parties will be
sorted and are sorting currently uh
under this paradigm i would think well
let's
we got we got to go to superchats
because we are running late oh cool but
let's uh
let's let's talk more about these this
political spectrum stuff and
constructivism in the in the members
only segment
for now let's read these uh super chats
if you haven't already smash
the like button if i've earned it and
you really like the show the like button
really does help
and subscribe hit the notification bell
and go to timcast.com become a member
and pick up by clicking shop
your diamond hands gorilla shirt or your
our pillow
because our pillow is better than my
personal pillow not the company actually
i'll say this
the my pillow is actually good and
probably better than my joke pillow but
get the joke pillow because it's funny
there you go
shout out to my pillow i guess all right
here we go uh
aaron tamicki says tim can you shout out
it's me
and can you shout out it's me and my
girlfriend's one year love you uh i love
you
lis did you mean liz aaron his
girlfriend's probably list
oh lis congratulations guys yeah shout
out for your one year
all right let's see we got here
the black blade says ian you might not
be married or have kids but did you know
that you are helping me become a better
husband and father
my seven of damascus steel would have
your back any day
thanks dude oh there you go man god's
work the wrong thinker says i can't wait
to re
retire and grow a jack murphy beard
don't wait if you're
if you're afraid that your employer
won't let you have a beer like this
do you want to work for them no
all right here's i'm like we have a
bunch of super chats coming in and i'm
like wow must be a good day a lot of
people are i wonder what's happening oh
the black blade says guess what stimulus
guess what i choose to invest in my
favorite alt media cheers friends hey
greatly appreciate it
if you got those stimulus checks i i see
a whole bunch of
you know it's one of the funniest things
in the world they're giving all these
people 1400
bucks some people don't need it and
they're just buying stocks with it
they're buying game stuff is it
financial advice
is it taxable yes it is yes that's
dumb it's like we're gonna give you
money but then take some back with your
own tax money we're going to pay you
and then unemployment is taxed it's
it's called no no it's called an
insurance payout it's smart it's smart
it's smart of course because that way
the people that made a lot of money
before they become unemployed
still have to pay taxes progressive rate
it's a way of diminishing the return of
that benefit to people that don't need
it
then why do a means-tested check where
they're like if you make certain amount
of money you don't get one
no just your taxes will cover that yeah
maybe i'm wrong on the taxation i think
you're absolutely right
at least i know for sure unemployment
i'm pretty sure on this though
i thought everybody my opinion is that
everybody should get that should do the
check
yeah you don't have to do means tested
if you just if it's taxable
and thrown on top of your agi i even
think billionaires should get a check
you know why
because there's not that many of them
and they're getting taxed on that
they're only going to end up getting a
couple hundred bucks
off of their income it's not that bad
maybe they get 1200 of it
or of the 1400 no no it is that bad
people don't people don't realize the
top tax bracket is not 90
oh let's throw in but let's talk about
all the other taxes on top
sales tax let's talk about the corporate
tax i'll talk about their employment tax
social security right you ain't got to
convince me taxes are bad people don't
understand that income tax is not the
only
issue taking money away from people who
are
true you know working and there's
actually net benefits wealthy people get
at a certain level like social security
tax stops at a certain number so you're
making a ton of money also in your check
gets bigger
i'm just saying that if we're already
taxing this if it's taxed my argument
was that
let's say you were making 150 a year and
so you got an apartment in new york
because your standard of living is there
and then covet hits and you lose your
job and now you can't everything you
budgeted for your phone bill your car
you got an auto loan you know your loan
is a couple hundred bucks a month or
whatever and now you're like
i can't pay these bills then you hear
about the stimulus and you're like oh
please
i need some money and they say oh but
not you because you're rich you made a
bunch of money last year it's like bro i
lost my job
i'm going to lose everything then you
have someone has a lower bracket
who deserves the money as well they're
budgeted for 50 000
they're clear and they can pay their
bills and they can maintain their center
of living
it's going to be knocking middle class
people down to lower middle class and
lower class
that's why i thought the means testing
was wrong and i'm like if you're going
to do a stimulus
it should be like unemployment benefits
and a stimulus for everybody
i think it might be taxed not taxed i
don't know um tax day got pushed back to
may 15th may
17th may 17th all right we got jeff bow
he says hey beanie crew
i was hoping you could shout out my
friend brock who introduced me to you
guys
you guys should talk about the
composition of the government budget
people don't know enough in my opinion
that's a good point
uh i watched a video from the from
gravel institute i think it's called
yeah and it was david cross talking
about why america sucks
and it was really good at first i was
really excited uh
they're well produced and he's basically
like look at all this we're spending in
taxes
and the problem is and then he goes into
healthcare costs and like inefficiency
of the healthcare industry and i was
like
you were so close bro you needed to say
only one thing the tax
dollars too much of it goes to blowing
up kids in foreign countries black
budget
yeah well we don't even know what it's
being spent right or like what was it
there's like a trillions of dollars
missing from the pentagon budget like
they didn't know where it went or
something
things like that and so i'm saying like
dude
if you come out you come to me and say
hey you know that we spend like
600 billion dollars on war i'd be like
okay
how much of that is like actual defense
of america
probably not as much as you'd think a
lot of it goes to these overseas
military bases and things like that
after that you can argue anything you
want to me like i need a billion dollars
for this program
oh yeah take it from the blown up kids
department right so there's a really
great argument for
for progressives if they start with uh
we're not gonna tax you more
we're just gonna take the money from the
things that are dumb and put towards
things that make more sense
and i think everyone then is gonna be
like okay i mean unless you get like
critical race theory stuff like the
green new deal
otherwise that's crazy all right
christina h says
by the way ian last week when i said you
look like ian hill of judas priest in
the 80s
i totally meant it as a compliment
thanks for all you guys do love you have
a great night i looked it up but oh
i didn't i don't think i got him i
didn't think i looked like him i feel
bad
why uh michael brogan says it's saint
patty's day enjoy that beer jack oh
you're right we should have all had a
beer jack
murphy jack formerly john goldman
now jack murphy it's a great name you
should embrace it
gold man john murphy explain the explain
the history john murphy gold
that's my full name yeah no and john and
jack is like a translatable
like indeed it is like um ah this is uh
like uh i gotta i gotta step on my saint
patty's day moment like that i think
it's a good move
good lord spencer prudhomme says tim
when's the tinfoil hat gorilla shirt
coming out i'll become a member just for
that
you know what you're right i have uh not
gotten that done and it's basically done
and it should be up
so we will do and i'll try and do this
by tomorrow
a limited edition tin foil hat i am a
gorilla shirt
tinfoil hat oh it looks pretty good we
have the graphic i just got to get it up
so uh the diamond hands one i didn't
really have a plan for i just thought it
was funny
like you know because the the the game
stop the wall street bets people have a
meme
you know apes together strong it's from
uh planet of the apes
and so i was like well we have this
shirt let's make one where he's like a
wall street guy with money that'll be
funny
apparently everybody really loves i like
the evolution of the gorilla he's become
a wall street creator we'll have to do a
gorilla in space
one day on mars with elon musk yeah all
right let's see
butters or uh oregano oregano
says glad you guys had rucka on the
other day i feel like he's so close to
breaking out of the dream world that is
objectivism
also glad you pushed back more fervently
near the end of the show
i i just think that look alan west said
things
i didn't necessarily agree with but i'm
not here to just
argue and like berate necessarily
although sometimes you know we've had
people on the show where we get into
pretty like
you know pretty legit arguments i do try
to be like okay here's a person who's
expressing their opinion
let's flesh out their opinion a little
bit and then if they say something i
really disagree with i'll push you back
you know but for the most part it's like
we're trying to learn from other people
and think
and figure out what they think all right
dv ken bravo says tim and crew
first sc here funny how the democrats
say that states that have constitutional
carry
or are two-way sanctuaries will turn to
the wild west when leftist-run cities
like minneapolis sure look like the okay
corral
you don't see chases in texas diamond
hands gorilla for life he says
that's right diamond hands gorilla yeah
that's funny what do you think would
happen if there's like a jazz in
texas i don't think it would work it's a
non-starter
yeah just wouldn't happen because the
guy who lives there would just walk
outside and be
like keep walking right although there
was that
you know dallas shooting stuff that
crazy guy shooting the cops i mean that
was crazy
yeah that got memory hold didn't it what
was that
when that guy that that gentleman of a
non-specific race
shot up a bunch of cops of specific
races a black identity extremist in
dallas started shooting at cops
when killed like six of them in the lead
in the run-up to the 2016 election yeah
uh oh yeah yeah all right let's see
april
fierce family g2g says china has
starvation to keep their people weak
under control the us's ideologies keep
us separated weak and under control
mental slavery to keep us from coming
together and fighting back media
propaganda and lack of knowledge
yeah except in china they have moved
more people out of poverty
into uh you know living conditions that
are sustainable than anybody in the
world
they have urbanized it rate faster than
anybody else in the world i have no idea
what that person's talking about
the nazis did that too what urban we
brought all those people out of poverty
i'm not saying that they didn't military
and it's funny uh the guys like stephen
pinker that we'll look around the world
and say oh democracy and freedom is
spreading and changing poverty
conditions and bringing people out of
poverty
they failed to mention that the number
one driving statistical force in people
coming out of poverty
is chinese authoritarian communism
interesting yeah never say that that's
how you get out of poverty really is the
key yeah
all right atex and says millennials are
depressed to your earlier point
we're rationally paying attention and
realizing our country isn't the one we
were promised in our youth
maga resonated for a reason with a lot
of people that's
absolutely i think a lot of the people
who uh
on the left vote democrat they just
watch the mainstream media and believe
what they're told
so to them it's like why aren't i
getting what i want
blame trump okay i will
blackrock beacon says i look forward to
things like hearing from
you uh your about me wait what like
hearing from you about me being your war
hazardous environment correspondent
former eod tech with special forces
deployment to afghanistan
trained and ready to go cool fantastic
yeah thank you
why you gotta be so awkward over there
ian alright j mack you got a big ol
super chat he says honestly after i got
medically retired from the military
was really depressed and lost purpose it
was the lowest point in my life
and i had a pretty rough childhood after
cutting junk food and excessive beer out
of my life i focused on my kids and
started starting a business
happiest i've ever been wow
congratulations dude
take action align yourself to the energy
of the universe action
is rewarded the gut biome is like we got
to have a gut biome expert on something
well south park did that episode
where they were trying to get physical
or you can positive bacteria into your
gut biomass all right absolute territory
says tim i have a favorite spatula and
i'm not depressed
i happen to be an amateur home chef
though and my favorite spatula just
works great
that was the one thing she said that i
didn't have any problem with you get
older you have a favorite spatula
i was using one to get the scoby out of
the kombucha it was an artifact of her
talking about how many brownie sheets
yeah right yeah april fierce family says
when you don't have an iden have
have an identity in god and find it
elsewhere that's why they created
identity politics and now
social warriors and legalized sin and
when that's filled to the brim you can
punch old ladies without a thought i
mean
it's a it's a it's a lack of a moral
framework there's none their moral
framework is based upon
if like it's not even about being having
a framework they have a very
clear and explicit moral framework no
they don't yes they do then why do they
it just doesn't just owens because
that's part it fits into their moral
framework they
have morals and we are in violation of
their morals
that's why they hate us that's why they
think that we're the evil that's why
they think we need to be put down
this really is an excellent excellent
example you're correct and saying they
have a moral
but my argument is they don't have the
right one a moral that is
agree with me or i'll beat you is not a
moral framework it is just a
a rudimentary like oh man
primitive their moral framework is is if
you don't work towards justice for
everybody you're actively working
against justice for everybody and
therefore you're evil define justice
in this moral framework it's their
definition that's the point i'm bringing
up there's
there's no way to define what they're
fighting for it's agree with them or
else
that's not a framework that is just a an
instinctual demand of
in tribe or not in tribe so how tim
do you see they even attack their own of
course they're going to so that's the
way it's going to end
it's not a moral framework when they
arbitrarily attack someone who agrees
with them
i think that you if we examine that
circumstance a little bit deeper we
would see perhaps that there
wasn't as clear as that but i'm just
bringing this up as a way to
to compare again it's not the absence of
a moral framework that's a problem
it's the adherence to crappy stupid
moral frameworks that's the problem
and that we've been given and presented
with the moral framework that works
now are we going to adhere to it or not
is the question all right all right we
got a very important super chat here
from from hayden
he says tim you often say that people
should move to the woods and build
things with their hands
this is one big problem money you have
to own the tract of force to build a
house in it
i want nothing more than to build a home
it costs tens of thousands
for the land alone do you know how much
it costs
for a half acre in west virginia fifteen
hundred bucks
yeah you can find that depending on
where you are in west virginia and
electricity
uh no raw actually no some have streams
some actually have access to some but
sure yeah but
in if you want to get closer to the
urban centers you can get a half acre
for five grand
now i don't know if they'll do a loan on
just five grand so maybe
you know you've got to save up a little
bit but maybe that's what you got to do
save up a little bit maybe it's just
going to be more difficult when you find
an acre for 1500 bucks and you probably
can
cheap middle of nowhere and you've got
to be completely suffer online but you
know what ends up happening
it's like i talked about the occupied
people who got that farm they realize
how hard it is to actually live
being self-reliant and it is just easier
to say
i'd rather just work at a fast food
restaurant it is easier to work at a
fast food restaurant there's really cool
prefab buildings with like gray water
systems built in and i think they're a
lot of prices solar
prices yeah probably like 20 relatives
relatively but you way more than that
you can cheap ones you can get some
pretty cheap prefab stuff
granted now we're talking of tens of
thousands of dollars
but if you get an acre of land with some
trees on it it's not
all that expensive it's not the easiest
thing in the world i'm actually saying
it is hard
that's the point but you're also kind of
like just pointing the direction i know
it is
it is hard you can't just be like hey
tomorrow go go buy that land but
aim for it it's not tim you're pointing
out a destination as people should head
to
i often do that too but really what
we're talking about is the spirit
the spirit of i will not accept my
current circumstances and i will do
everything i can
to change them to improve them i will
forget about my vices i will forget
about my
entertainment i will dedicate myself to
solving this problem because i'm an
independent autoregulating man
or woman whatever point is is you just
have to
take this attitude of i can
not the attitude of i can't that's
exactly it
so i'm not i shouldn't literally like i
think it's an extreme example like go in
the woods and build a house with sticks
what i'm actually just saying is be a
pioneer you know uh
find the heaviest thing you can carry
and carry it whether
it's go into your like living room and
just start drawing pictures
something you don't normally do honestly
i think people should go for walks i
think people should literally like if
you play video games all day
turn out a podcast and go for a walk no
joke it will change your life
if you're not active and and i know a
lot of people probably can't probably
can't go for walks because of covet or
whatever but if you can find the time
like even watching this show i don't go
walk around in the middle of the night
or whatever
when it's dark out or something but a
lot of people will listen to this show
in the next day or so get up early in
the morning just go walk around a little
bit
you'll see some squirrels doing squirrel
stuff that's always funny right you know
squirrels are silly
saving the world starts in the squat
rack i mean that literally and
figuratively you save yourself save
society
save everything by getting fit and
strong make it the number one most
important priority in your life after
sleep
yeah and drink water yeah when you when
you wake up you want to drink some water
basically it'll change your life you
know because when you're sleeping for
you know seven eight hours or however
long you sleep you're not drinking any
water you wake up dehydrated
immediately slam some water and you will
feel like a millionaire go to the
bathroom when you need to go to the
bathroom your body
is doesn't know when if you if your body
has wants and needs and
it doesn't understand not giving it tell
me about it your body is once and
i'm not going to get into it on the show
jack i'll tell you afterwards thank you
definitely all right
members only jonathan galterini says
check out jack posobik on twitter
he got military people to send him the
latest on biden's new extremism
training for ratting out extremists oh
yeah nobody ever knew anyone
so they altered the definition to fit
right-wing extremism
yeah cause people would people were like
what does extremism look like to you
what have you seen and that and the
troops were like
well you know when antifa was attacking
that federal courthouse and
and portland yeah and then the people
running the thing we're like no that's
not what we're talking about
there you go all right the military is
in trouble
yeah that's what allen was saying last
night big time
he's a leader yeah we're gonna get we're
gonna break apart we're gonna get
crushed i am not optimistic in that
regard
it's so weird we need allies give me i
mean look it's
at one it is the most bountiful time to
be alive
look at you tim no high school no
college
bust your ass for real guys tim pool
works harder than anybody i know
bust your ass and here you are there's
about this is the most bountiful time to
be alive but at the same time
it is very difficult to not be just
horribly pessimistic i think people have
been conditioned not to work hard
or to not know how to i can't they've
been conditioned to i can't
you don't need to you probably used to
need to but now you can hold on get by
with kind of wasn't doing much
was it james lindsay told us this i
can't remember if it was him someone
said
they were playing world of warcraft and
they were building up this character
and then eventually realized like all of
the all that time and energy i'm putting
into making this really awesome
character
i could make myself really awesome there
is no
no better feeling than leveling up your
real life
leveling up your real life is the best
dude making youtube videos
and watching the analytics is like a
role-playing game you're like oh my my
numbers are going up i'm watching the
value of the comments of
the communication my skills are
increasing so insane though
yeah i mean life is insane no especially
when your numbers go down and you think
it's you but it's really just right
right you've got to reach you can you
eventually learn that it's trans worst
thing in the world detach from the
personalization of it
social media is a plague an addiction
and it's destroying the minds of people
because they don't understand
human behavior and how networks work and
so what happens is
they make a youtube video they get a
million views they feel really good
about themselves and then here comes
like summer time and everyone goes out
to play in the yard and don't watch
youtube videos
and they only get a hundred thousand
views and become depressed and then quit
because they don't understand what
they're doing wrong so they're not doing
anything well
it happens all the time but for you it
didn't like you know
this affects everybody and i get like i
mentioned i'm getting hit up all the
time right now
i get like 10 people hitting up the past
week yo dude they're suppressing my
content what do i do i'm freaking out
i'm like stop
nothing you're doing nothing i'm just
happened to be i guess
uh knowledgeable in the industry
tracking media ratings
you're seeing persistence listen when i
first started doing this i understood
how ratings worked
i understand how seasons worked when one
day it rained viewership went up and i
laughed i'm like it's raining on the
east coast major storm so everyone's
inside
but people don't get this and social
media makes them go insane
because they don't know how to make
these systems work properly you don't
want to over analyze it you know what is
simple for people for leveling up
going for a run and being like wow i ran
a minute longer than last time
yeah but also saying something you
believe and then seeing people respond
you're like oh
it's better than a video game no yeah
and right it's an addiction it's
dangerous
people then become extremists on social
media advocating for violence
bro social media is is is diseasing
people's brains
it's a whole bunch but it's also a
career so i mean it's it's how you use a
dangerous tool we need to be using
people's brains right now i don't think
so i didn't say
every single person on social media and
every element of it yeah but social
media as a system
does disease some people's brains yeah
no no no not can it literally does
well i was gonna say disease someone
does disease
people are getting surgery to look like
instagram filters is crazy i was going
to bring that up earlier
it's making people go nuts sad right the
point i'm playing
people is being powerful and it's better
than a video game what i'm saying what
i'm saying is there are a lot of things
you can do to trigger a dopamine release
to make you feel good and the simplest
and easiest thing anyone can do is go
for a walk i used to hang out with bill
ottman when we were building minds and i
was playing video games he's like i was
like don't you play video games he's
like this is my video game dude and he
was like coding
of course it's way better going for a
walk is where you start
and then finding local events that's why
i love going to skate parks
skateboarding
because you instantly have a shared
community you know i i can guarantee you
i can jump at a skate park and i can
have a conversation with anyone what was
the last time you rolled up on a skate
park
just like a month and a half ago and
were did did you have any moment of
chill time just being tim
did people recognize you no i don't know
i went to a skate park he wrote around
and it was silly and the ground sucked
and no one recognized you no they were
like 13
14 years old that's crazy very few older
people they got kids man
i go i go out to dinner in dc and the
waitress recognizes me and as i'm
leaving yeah she comes with 8000 years
old
true i'm at a skate park oh 13 year old
kids mostly kids hang out kids the
adults are now working or doing whatever
they're doing people quit skateboarding
and there's a reason why it's been a
month and a half since i've gone back to
a scale park because i also work granted
we have a skatepark here
so it's you know three of them two of
them two of them you know
but i know i know this and this is why
skateboarding is so great
you go to a skate park you will meet
people and you can instantly have a
conversation and a community
share ideas and encourage each other
clap and cheer for each other
and it's always there now in in with
code and everything it's kind of been
getting pretty bad
you know people people haven't been
going out but if you get the chance but
we do gotta read some more super chat so
we got oliver moreland says hey gang
greetings from minnesota
we have blue cities but every other
country in the state is
ever the county in the state is red
rocks and cows is holding a king walt's
protest during his speech this sunday
the hatred towards him in the state is
insane but well deserved
there's a cultural split between cities
and
outside of cities i was reading a study
that said even in red states
cities are blue it's the weirdest thing
i went to a small town in a red state
and they had black lives matter flags
everywhere
you go a mile out trump flags everywhere
i'm like that's weird
why is that the city was only a few
thousand people
but for some reason it turned blue it's
weird
tyler b says truck drivers are in super
high demand companies pay like three to
four k
cost for training them to make 40k your
first year i'm four years in
74k and debt free at 28. it's a matter
of wanting it bad enough
no excuses be a truck driver for no out
of pocket
dude that was always that's always like
a tempting job man road trips
my brother did that for like two plus
years or something i'm sure at a certain
point you're just driving and it's a job
but i love road trips man you go on the
road you're stopping at the rest stop
you get to see little knickknacks they
got you get to meet people talk about
stuff you got the radio playing road
trips are fun man trucking sounds like a
fun job
all right we got pavimera says it's fun
job until you're away from your family
for four days at a time then when you
come back you want to sleep for three
days
yeah maybe it's a young man's game man i
don't know that's why why do you think
it pays well
relative to the training and education
is required yeah
because it sucks it's hard work i don't
know
i mean he said he wanted it you have to
pay men to be away from their family
that's true that's the thing
a lot of the things that you say are
based on your perspective and it's for
sure of single
and not and not having family because i
just would never the thought would just
never cross my mind that like
being away from my kids for a week at a
time would be a good idea under any
condition
yeah but what about your significant
other yeah same i don't want to be away
from her either
come with me babe yeah you bring her
with yeah so what's the there you go
no but as a trucker you can't do that
i'm saying she travels with me now
i mean maybe you could right nice yeah
all right we got pavi mara says indian
guy in portland here
you guys definitely are a silly people
with all the contemporary bs and the
culture war
and it's the low t people women mainly
who are the mouthpieces for the bs
well there you go what do they do in
india sweeping generalization
yeah right women are generally low t i
guess you're i know
that's not an insult that's just well i
guess that's that's essentialism
the opposite is an insult
says i agree tim we need to make our own
games again i want
twisted metal again but if the big devs
make it it will be woke like twisted
metal three and completely missed the
point of why we loved that gang
twisted metal was awesome yeah i love
that gang shadow
that was the gray car was it yeah he's
great hog
are they in a remake leisure suit larry
what is that that was like a
point-and-click game
like kind of like king's quest but you
were this dude who was like the sex
addict
with like a suit it was basically one
step up from oregon trail
hey and it was about trying to be like a
ladies man
there was it would you when we were
younger you thought that there was going
to be like
boobs in it or pouring in something when
there wasn't porn all over the place and
you're 14
just the notion of being able to see a
breast was like super exciting
we got a video game coming out we got a
video game it's pretty hot we haven't
been talking about it
do you want to talk about it not not too
much maybe a little bit but i'm
wondering like what
if is there a timetable and when we
think it might be six months to eight
months really at the rate we're going
yeah
we could probably speed that up if we
wanted to it's a culture war themed
rogue like a game that's going to be fun
and hilarious and it only uses cartoon
violence
and i guess i'll just say this i don't
know if i'm supposed to but uh
freedom tunes is doing the cartoon work
so it's literally going to be like a
freedom tunes video
it's very cool yeah we're trying to make
it really fun and funny
and it's going to be cartoon violence
because video games always have some
element like mario smashes turtles by
crushing them and like you know kicking
them
but we're going to have more silly like
big rubber mallets and like punching
gloves and stuff like that
bone arrow that shoots like plungers
yeah plungers and stuff
but it's a a rogue-like game so it's
like you know you're a little guy it's a
platformer sort of and you're like
making your way
i don't want to give away too much
information but it's uh it's it's it's
freedom tunes
you've seen many more that's one of my
favorite things to do is to create video
games sorry to cut
yeah no i think we should make like uh
we should we do
we want to open source it and we want to
have it so that people can develop their
own items and mods and things like that
and
there's going to be like items and
combos and it's going to be you
the future of video games that like when
you log into your
playstation network or whatever your
team whatever you want to call it you
have like an avatar
and then when you play a game anything
you do in that game
gets you abilities that go back to your
account that you can take to other games
that you play
i'll stop you right there i had an idea
um i was talking with nishra about this
i think
where you have a general accomplishments
app on your phone
with a character that you level up get
new weapons
and you can do mini games or whatever
but you level up the character
by 5 000 steps you earn 100 experience
points
you know so certain things that you can
do and you can track on your phone like
travel five miles not just even walking
like go
out of your house and go drive somewhere
even if it's in your car by yourself for
a drive
and then what happens is it tracks it
and then your character levels up and
it's actually just a personal
thing and that could unlock abilities
and items in the video games that
are no mine was mine was just like how
do you make a really awesome character
you can show off
and generate this little thing and every
day you com you get five steps you know
five
thousand steps like something happens
this is an idea all right we gotta read
a super chat here we got wandering mage
who says
i need to change i'm leaving behind my
old hobbies video games mtg
etc i'm reinventing myself getting back
into reading studying philosophy
working out reading my bible i think i
might try scuba diving why not right
absolutely yeah
i think magic the gathering went nuts
the power creep is insane
and it's just a ridiculous game now
which which is a bummer i guess you need
different formats to make the game work
better i want to scuba dive off the
malaysian coast
southeast asia where that flood took out
the moo people
um apparently it says that's that was
the ancient culture that rivaled
atlantis
all right a bunch of super chats come in
william
zhang hey tim check out project apple
appleseed rifle marksmanship clinics two
days of instruction along with history
of battles of lexington and concord hey
that's cool
they have appleseed all over the country
you can go and do a marksmanship course
and compare with your buddies all across
the country
right on there was a big super chat
where did that one go because youtube
jumps and then it skips over all of them
a lot of talk about star trek from very
smart people that's right
meridian forest says hey tim air force
service member here
getting promoted tomorrow to e4 so i
thought i'd share a little bit of my
paycheck with you love your content love
what you're doing keep up the good work
and tell ian he's a valued and respected
man on the show dude
amen congratulations on the promotion
man and i was going to say that
even if you didn't mention my name but
thank you they meant that thanks jack
people people come to my channel to talk
to me about you and my comments i should
come on your show someday you should
and then we can just have at it with the
comments oh finally
let's see okay just read i'm trying to
i'm reading through some super chats
here
roberto flores says star trek the
original series episode patterns of
force
they drug and prop up the fuhrer to
speak on tv
but he's manipulating manipulated by the
nazi party to say what they want
like how biden is propped up is that
what is that yeah
i'm not the biggest fan of the original
series but i'm a fan of the original
series the next generation i've seen
every episode numerous times
were you big on the first series i
watched them you know i'm not that old
bro
but by the time that you know i would
come home from school there'd be a
couple reruns on
i've seen a lot of them i think all
right troy dunham says tim jack ian
thank you
this is the discussion we need you asked
where it is it's here we love our
culture and we're finding it here
thanks tonight's episode is what we
can't find anywhere tired of hearing
about aoc
right on that's the other thing too it's
like i i've tried to make sure that like
my references to her have avoided the
stupid petty garbage because i
definitely played that game before
now i'm trying to be like i only want to
say nice things about people when i get
the opportunity to do it
if they do something dumb i'll criticize
them but aoc did the thing in taxes for
millions of dollars helped people out
that's rad
yeah deserves credit for that i don't
wanna i don't wanna just you know
it goes a long way too positive
reinforcement that's right
i want all the politicians to go into
like a a help of the poor off
like you know ted cruz versus aoc who
can help more poor people and like make
their communities better aha
that would be great that would actually
be really hilarious like ted cruz uses
standard conservative values to try and
improve the lives of the people in his
community
aoc uses progressive values and then we
like we give them a score based on how
well they've done
like has employment gone up and then you
know what i mean i mean
isn't the basic difference teaching man
to fish or give a man to fish
don't we know how hey look i think if
people's lives are improving let's let's
roll with it you know what i mean
and make it a positive thing which you
know well maybe maybe it won't maybe
some ideas are bad ideas we'll see what
happens teaching a man to fish
that's not starving is nice well here's
the way i put it
they say if you give a man a fish you
feed him for a day
if you teach a man to fish you feed him
for the rest of his life
assuming he has a fishing fishing pole
oh
you've thought so deep so my thing is
i'm not going to give a man a fish
i'm going to teach him how to fish give
him a fishing pole and say now you're on
your own
show them where the water is right so
there's there's and then make them drink
and then stand behind them and drink the
water all right here we go rachel knight
online says hi tim
as long as we're mixing our metaphors
hi tim big fan from el paso nato
o'rourke
is the man who did nothing for our
district when he was our congressman
lost in his senate senate bid
embarrassingly lost in his presidential
bid
and is now looking to run for governor
what are your thoughts
your federal congress person does not
represent
does not improve your district they
represent your district at the federal
government
so if the roads are dirty and
everything's all messed up you got to
vote locally
uh i also think beto o'rourke is not a
good politician
you know i keep i'm i want to keep the
language lighter i don't i don't you
know maybe in private i'll say some
worse things about him and
some other individuals but i'm not a fan
of beto i think
he's duplicitous you know he said he
wanted to take everyone's guns
um
i'll give them respect for actually
being able to stand on a skateboard but
let me tell you something
probably cool dude somebody who's been
skating most of their life when you see
someone jump on a board
you know if they will be able to
actually perform on a skateboard
beta o'rourke can stand on the board and
ride it fine he gets some respect for
that
but i can tell the dude couldn't do a
trick to save his own life
there you go not calling you out that's
right play game of thrones all right
trevor farrell do a couple more here
he says hey you guys are awesome and
listening to jack is always a treat keep
your chin up and keep
up the good in the keep up the good the
good the fight thank you fight
appreciate it all right last one mitch
devine says 25 year old army vet here
looking at a 100 to 200 acre ranch and
taking a
distilling class to open my own
distillery here in texas right on
you know what here's what we're going to
do
we're going to talk about politics a
little bit but i want to talk about what
everyone is calling the biden cgi video
because i'm going to surprise everybody
i'm going to debunk it
but if you want to watch we're going to
do an extended segment for members only
exclusive at timcast.com so go over
there become a member and that'll be up
in about maybe 45 minutes or more
depending on how long the
the special segment goes but we got a
ton of really awesome segments a whole
library of content you can go check out
from other people
so everybody smash that like button
before you go subscribe hit the
notification bell you can follow me on
all social media platforms at tim cast
my other youtube channels
youtube.comcast youtube.comcastnews and
this show
tim cast irl is live monday through
friday at 8 p.m so we will be back
tomorrow
leave us a good review smash the like
button give us five stars all that good
stuff and share it with your friends if
you really like it that's the key
jack you want to shout out what you got
going on i do come to my youtube channel
jack murphy live i've got a show
tomorrow at 12 noon with jesse kelly
me and him both over six foot four
that's gonna be awesome
and then on friday live at noon i've got
uh corey d'angelos christopher ruffo and
carlin oh
wow all-star panel
and uh coming up after that we got
michael anton and curtis jarvin coming
so
things are really picking up jack murphy
live also follow me on twitter
actually everywhere on the internet jack
murphy live thank you
jack murphy live everywhere uh you guys
can follow me ian crossland at ian
crossland.net and i love your comments
so keep them coming leave a comment on
the video i like reading the uh you're
welcome
i will i'll leave 20 comments tomorrow
just use sock puppets okay
thanks everyone and i'm sour patch litz
over on twitter and also on minds
we will see you talking about biden and
cgi and politics at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out
you